the following is a presentation of the
St Louis chess club
the kings of Chess are reigning on high
at the super bet chess classic in
Bucharest Romania spectacular play Wild
Spectators as players put on a show for
their adoring fans Fabiano caruana was
all business quickly dispatching Maxine
Bashir lagrah for his first win janapo
niaci once again blew a clear advantage
against Nemesis and new world champion
ding lerin settling for a draw there's a
tie at the top who will break away from
the pack day four of incredible chess
coming up next
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back everybody to day four of
the 2023 Superbad chess Classic held in
Bucharest Romania we start day 4 in
front of the Romanian National Art
Museum we have incredible pieces here if
you find yourself in Bucharest make sure
you check it out now let's go to the
studio and start the action for day four
we welcome you to the first stop on the
2023 grandchild store and our coverage
of super bedroom Mania we come to your
life from the San Luis chess club
[Music]
hello and welcome everyone thanks for
joining our show I'm International
Master now surprise and I'm here with
Grandmaster yasu sarawan Nasi it's been
a pleasure calling all the action with
you and varusian really a lot of fun yes
I agree absolutely hello everyone and
thank you for sharing your day with us
as we get ready for round four they say
it's Lonely at the Top not so at the
super bet tournament as we have four
players sharing the first place let's
take a look at the standings let's take
a look
we have four co-leaders American Fabiano
caruana representing fide
another American Wesley so and Romanian
Richard rapper world champion on the
outside looking in right so far with all
draws we have dinkleren from China and
Anish giri from Netherlands and with one
point we have two Frenchmen alireza
fieruja in mvl Poland's number one young
Christoph Duda and Romanian bogda Daniel
dieck and our format
we have a 10 player round robin
tournament with a classical band control
90 minutes for the first 40 moves 30
minutes for the rest of the game and 30
second increment from move one
there are no droppers allowed and
players get one point for a win half for
a draw and zero for a loss and our
remaining schedule for the tournament
right we have total of nine routes and
today players are playing round four on
Thursday they will have a rest day and
after that they'll be back to finish
with four rounds wonderful and we're
very fortunate to have in Studio Grand
Master of uruguesian VAR how did these
four players get here thank you yes sir
it's been very exciting tournament and
so far we saw a lot of interesting games
and let's take a look how the players
got there
so first we have Fabiano caruana on plus
one but in fact he could have been plus
two he missed a clear win in the first
game against deak he drew against
dingley Wren and yesterday he had a very
impressive win against nuel
then we have Nepal who started out with
the drogance report and he had some
opportunities in that game it was a
French defense if you remember but he
misplayed so it ended in a draw then he
won against the act with the Blackfish
and again yesterday he had great
opportunities getting a winning position
out of the opening but then letting
think back in the game and the game
ended in a draw
then we have Wesley saw so far I think
he's been very impressive very solid he
won the first game with the black pieces
against fioruga had some opportunities
in a second game again with the black
page against nvl but he decided to play
it safe and secure the draw and he was
also pressing anishikiri a little bit
and but the game ended in a draw
and then we have Richard Report with
plus one score draw against Nepal win
against Duda from a very very equal end
game and then he drew against firusha
yesterday and we're gonna go to Romania
to our friend Grandmaster Christian
chirilla
thanks Warren welcome back chess fans to
day four here at the 2023 super bet
chess classic in Bucharest Romania and
what a tournament we've had up to this
point so much Fighting Chess and I have
to say and I want to build up on uh
these incredible players that you
highlighted VAR and one big matchup is
the one between janapo miyashi with the
black pieces against Fabiano caruana
with the white pieces he is having two
white pieces in a row yesterday's game
against mvl for Fabiano that was just a
breakthrough event just an incredible
miniature with the white pieces that
move three H4 launching a vicious attack
against mvl's King that was just an
incredible game and incredible
showcasing from Fabiano by the Anna from
yashi I have to say he had an incredible
chance as well yesterday in his matchup
against digly ran unfortunately for him
he fell short and surely he will be
slight slightly disappointed about that
game but we know how resilient these
players are another big matchup that I'm
having my eyes on is the one between the
young Romanian Bogdan Daniel Deck with
the white pieces against Ali Reza firuja
both of these players are on minus one
so they're definitely having their eyes
set on a victory and we know alireza
even with the black pieces he can
definitely strike he is the defending
2022 champion of the grand Chester and
right now he has a difficult task ahead
of himself because despite the fact that
Bogdan Daniel deck has been struggling
with the white pieces he is extremely
solid he's not giving you a single inch
on the chessboard so definitely this one
is going to be a highly contested
matchup guys we have so many exciting
chess the atmosphere here is
electrifying the chess fans are ready to
get involved as well are ready to see
some exciting chess thank you Christian
and indeed set the table for us tell our
viewers what they could expect in
today's round four pairings right let's
take a look at the pairings we have
Maxima Sheila Grove playing an ishqiri
and our two co-leaders which are wrapper
huge matchups still playing each other
nice we have diac against ferrugia as
mentioned our new Champion Dinkley Ram
playing Duda he's going to be looking
for his first win no question and
another leaders facing each other
Carolina against the publisher and the
players are all fighting very hard it
looks like our leaders could even have
more points and what are they fighting
so hard for right they're fighting for a
lot of money we have total price fund of
350 000 and the first place winner is
going to get one hundred thousand
dollars second place 65 000 30 48 000.
very nice incentives as you can see a
price panel all the way down to 10th and
final place of 10 thousand dollars Grand
Chester points up for grabs as well get
as many as you can and
it looks like some celebrities in the
house
kind of pointing out what you got to do
in terms of getting uh the ceremonial
first move it looks like Gary's gonna
lead off today
he's in robust
welcome at the fourth round of services
Three Special guests today for the
opening ceremony again
the play at two of the youngest players
in the world rankings
play today and The Grandmaster will make
the official person
before
HD
watching Gary play one two two D4 even
as an opening server that wasn't his up
go-to he like eat to eat for uh got most
of his career
but at least we didn't hate it as much
as Knight F3 no no exactly
D4
[Music]
Romanian football participants
a lot of goals sold for Romania and now
making the first book here in chess it's
everywhere with us helping promoting
this beautiful tournament and this
beautiful sport objects
and I noticed he was wearing the golden
shoes did you pick up on that
no it was actually a very nice tan
looking shoes for boys
but handsome here
let's do it again
[Music]
I have to say that for Dean Lauren the
world champion and our pick
at winning the tournament I don't think
he's happy with the first three rounds
he played two draws with whites in
rounds one and two yesterday around
three he was definitely seriously worse
pretty Assurance against me about
yesterday yeah but once again he shows
his resilience he refuses to lose losing
positions he just Bears down somehow
finds some counter play and today he's
sitting there saying okay I've got to
join this group of people to start
winning yeah I've got white I've got I'm
playing dude sorry Duda I know you're a
really really good player but you're
suffering too you're you're minus one in
fact so I've got to take my chances and
try to beat you
Umar you were mentioning in how the
players got here that they could have
scored a lot more points including nepo
including Wesley including Fabi I mean
everybody could have scored more points
but they only scored one Victory I've
definitely could have been on plus two
Jan also could have been on plus two
yesterday he had a very nice Advantage
Wesley had some chances in the round two
against uh yes nvl and also yesterday he
had some chance against Anish as well
right so definitely plus two was a
possible score from these players yeah
uh D D4 by Fabi again showing his
flexible approach
D5 pardon me Knight F6 Knight F3 uh
again kind of a a Vladimir kramnik like
move order are we going to say catalog
or I was going to ask are we going to
see a Queen's Gambit accepted also a
possibility interesting so E7 E6 would
be your pick huh yes so E6
and I I think in that case the Catalan
is a very good uh likelihood
I think Fabi played against catalani in
round one
yes or as black round two maybe yes
against England yes I think maybe it was
round two Knight C3 inviting Bishop B4
okay uh tarash these days C takes D5
Knight takes D5 and very quickly E2 E3
now this line of play goes way way way
back 50s and 60s against E2 E3
the inclusion of a7a6 was considered the
right way of of meeting the move Ace e e
to E3 the idea behind A6 is you're
waiting like please move your Bishop
just move your bishop and guess what we
are in a Queen's Gambit accepted we're
actually black has a gained a Tempo and
then the the funny part it was against
A7 A6 a lot of people felt that the
right way is to play A3 and Knight C6
and Away you go instead we did see E3
Knight C6
C takes D5 e takes D5 Bishop B5
um
has this become a thing these days VAR
oh yeah this is definitely a major
theory yes sir and a lot of games played
in this position so I I actually played
in myself this as black I used to play
the tarash for a very long time no uh I
prepared for your stupid Terrace I I
like that movie A6 that you mentioned
earlier I liked a little bit better but
this line is very interesting too as we
can see both players are moving pretty
fast here let's take a look what the
theory looks like after this move Bishop
D7 here so we have total of about 130
games played in this position after
castle and Bishop D6 is the main move
here almost everyone played and I see
some big names here Grace shook played
as black few games body scale font and
they all made drills here so looks like
this line is actually playable Bishop D6
and now white plays here Knight F3 the
main move here and now just attacking
the pawn on D5 and you have a few
different options here you can play them
move A6 you can play also Bishop Bishop
E6 Bishop G4 is another possibility
because here you cannot take on D5
because of the Knight xd5 idea and queen
takes the file will lose to Bishop H to
check and black will pick up the queen
on D5 so lots of theory here and I think
black has some options here and he can
choose A6 Bishop G4 Bishop B6 but the
results show that the black is actually
doing okay here all right thank you uh
VAR uh in our other Marquee matchup of
our Clash of tournament leaders if you
will Richie Rapport open with the
English one C4 and after Knight F6
strangely enough stop they're both like
well I mean Richie you play C4 Knight I
mean thank you Knight C3 a little bit of
a pause I'm not too sure what the pause
was all about whether I think you're
choosing the move order yeah sometimes
you try to you know you you're thinking
to yourself if my opponent plays the
symmetrical English do I want to commit
my knight to C3 right if my opponent
plays E7 E5 the reverse Sicilian kind of
English would I prefer my pollen to be
on G3 and yeah getting those move order
right
is an art form by the way I mean it's
just uh it's so nice and uh some of the
old guys like Victor korchnoy he often
times spent and I'm not kidding like 30
minutes as much as 50 minutes on the
first 10 moves and he knows them
backwards and forwards it's like he's
trying to get a particular outcome from
the opening it's not always so easy so
the four nights English uh we've been
seeing E2 E4 we've been I mean just
basically everything under the Sun from
E3 D3 G3 uh and and a move uh that Bob
thenick and others have essayed as well
include D4 E4 and it just goes on
uh these two wow uh Wesley
really has a two-point lead yeah very
very nice uh score against Richie out of
the five games they've played Wesley has
never lost and I'm looking pretty good
there yeah nice feeling confident about
that Richard's looking to get that first
one exactly G2 G3 and uh we are in the
what I always thought was the main main
mind stuff of the English D7 D5 and this
was a near religion when I was playing
it was kind of a reverse Dragon
everybody but today against Bishop G2
remarkably enough should take uncouth or
even grishek's Bishop C5 I mean they're
experimenting and indeed Wesley said you
know what Sasha uh is kind of like
leading the parade and Bishop C5 has
been kind of got go-to move and after
castles you can consider the Knight take
C3 and you can consider Retreats I
remember
I was playing against Michael tall and
tall
again it played The Retreat and without
thinking I had played like a a silly
move D2 D3 instead of waiting uh I
should castle and he kind of gave me one
of those Michael Tall looks because I
had I had made a mistake in the opening
like young punk no no nothing you don't
know nothing VAR what don't we know
about Bishop C5 uh definitely the bishop
C5 has been a popular move for the last
few years and there are a lot of games
played here we can check some of the
theory so Bishop C5 here now we have
about 235 games played according to my
database and the main move here is
actually just to Castle
and black will black has some options
but again the main move just would be to
Castle and D3
and here where black has some options
here you can play the move H6 is is one
option here another move is rookie eight
and also Bishop B6 is played in this
position as well so after H6 for example
white can capture on D5 Queen takes D5
and now play the move Bishop D2 We Know
oftentimes in this positions white plays
Bishop D2 and then puts the bishop on C3
here and uh we see a game of Magnus
Carlsen winning with the white pieces
against Anish giri in 2022
so here Rook d8 is an option Queen D3
even A5 played but engine is showing
that the black position is absolutely
equal
there is another game that caught my eye
yes or very interesting as a scotch so I
wanted to maybe jump on that one and
take a look here so this is the game mvl
against Anish giri and as we know nvl
lost yesterday pretty bad game here so
he's definitely looking forward to try
to play an aggressive game here and try
to win this game so that's why we see
that a very very aggressive opening
Choice here so he just played the move
H4 and looks like this uh actually
perhaps surprise Anish has been thinking
for about five six minutes already here
so in this position uh it started off
with
uh just a normal Scotch here again yeah
Bishop C4 Italian Bishop B5 the Spanish
but mvl played deforge takes 94 Knight
F6 another main move here black can play
the move Bishop C5 here
so after Knight F6 white has the option
to play Knight C3 here as well which is
considered a little bit more solid and
then we have the bishop before there but
white went for this very sharp Knight
takes C6 btx C6 E5 attacking the Knight
and now Queen E7
has a very important move to pin the
pawn and it's uh it's not easy to defend
this Pawn for example if you play the
move F4 then you're gonna run it to the
six ID and then black will capture only
five and will have very good counter
play so that's why 95 Queen E2 is played
Knight D5 and here is actually a major
major Theory here almost 5 000 games
played here and the the most popular
movie is actually C4 for many years a
lot of games played about 4 000 games
but and we have played the move H4 here
there are other moves here too as well
like 92 for example G3 but H4 is the
second most popular move here and we
don't have any more moves after this the
point of this move is you want to secure
the G5 Sphere for the bishop so you have
that and at some point you can also play
Rook H3 and try to bring the Rook on the
third rank here so Anisha is still
thinking and looks like a pretty good
opening choice so far definitely Anish
was not expecting this I think from mvl
yeah these old scotch lines can be very
sharp and if you're not well prepared
you can somehow fall into
awkward uh situations uh the move h2h4
was actually introduced to to me by a
grand master from Holland
um
John vanderville and when when John
played H4 for the first time I I was
laughing so what's what on Earth is the
idea of H4 so the idea is that in this
line of the scotch this night on D5 has
a little bit of an awkward uh problem
and oftentimes you play the move C2 C4
seeking to force the Knight away from
the center and onto a relatively passive
Square on B6 once you can get the Knight
to B6 white usually gets a very nice
Advantage when the Knight is just kind
of stuck there the problem with the
immediate C4 is it runs into this very
strange idea of Bishop A6 just reminding
white that he's in a pin
anything to yourself okay I can play
b2b3 and just as VAR was mentioning
thousands of games have occurred from
this position now if we let's just take
a look at their head-to-head uh match up
by the way
I I knew they played a lot of games oh
my god
wow but I'm a little impressed there
that Anish has gotten the better of
MBL with the three wins fight losses in
a classic classical chess uh the idea of
sc4 Bishop A6 again very very well known
and Along Comes H4 so I say to Johnny
what on Earth is H4 he says well I'm
waiting for you to do something so the
idea is we're going to make a move yeah
the G6 I go C4 you go Bishop A6 oh
excuse me C4 Bishop A6 I want to go Rook
H3 with the idea of Rook Hey I loved it
when I first discovered this idea I
laughed it laughed it laughed so unusual
and it approached against all the
principles of the opening absolutely
just throw away all your opening uh
principles as I understand it the
problem with H4 is actually the move in
E6
so neither the queen is particularly
well placed on E2 uh blocking the bishop
and neither is the queen particularly
well placed on E7 which blocks the
bishop with a move Queen E6 kind of
dodges a lot of the problems one of the
things it does is it actually gives a
knight a different route now c4 Knight
moves not so bad black is ready to play
D6 black is ready in the number of cases
just to get on with business of Bishop
B7 and playing uh castles or what have
you so h2h4 gives the second player a
large variety of possible options and
we'll see what Anish comes up with I
wanted to say
I
win yes I think we both saw a2a3 went
like what is going on yes I'm gonna
guess this was also a Richard's idea yes
yes I think that that the trading with
ding and uh and Richard somehow uh has
made a technically not really Catalan
because white hasn't played C4 yet
correct but to start with move A3 right
I I have no idea what the idea is I'm
going to wait for the post-game
interview as well because uh
first of all is a2a3 a novelty
um avar uh it's not a novelty yeah sir
but it's not enough no there's some
games played after this only nine games
actually played after a three actually
the position this position occurred many
many times almost uh 1800 games or more
actually right so A3 here I'm trying to
see something actually Mama diaro played
this the the hyper the high profile game
is mamidaro against uh our friend Lanier
Dominguez from 2015. so two very very
big names yes and here's a black uh
played Knight bd7 couple of times there
is really not much Theory here you can
play B6 907 but do that I think knew
something about this and played the B5
pretty quickly maybe he knew this move
and this is a already a novelty there
are no more games played in this
position after B5 of course the main
idea is trying to prevent this move C4
because without C4 it's going to be very
hard for white to obtain any kind of
advantage or pressure on the center on a
queen side so that why he played the
move B5 and since you already played A3
you're not likely to spend another
attempting to play this movie four
because now black can just play before
for example so Knight C3 played
relatively quickly here by ding Loren I
think he's still in his prep here and
now he's trying to attack the pawn here
so now black has to respond here and he
has few options here A6 looks like the
most logical move and I think we're
probably gonna see this idea moving the
Knight either to E5 or even Knight D2
here the point of 92 here is if you play
Bishop B7 I actually can play the move
E4 right and try to get E5 maybe F4
Knight E2 and get some space advantage
and play for F5 so but black can take
only four here and then we're gonna
capture back with this Knight
threatening Knight takes F6 check
picking up the bishop on B7 so for
example Knight takes E4 Knight takes C4
and black will play the move Bishop D5
uh I like this move it's solidifying the
position Bishop is no longer going to be
hanging in a lot of these variations and
the black wants to play the move Knight
D7 and try to prepare C5 I think once he
plays the move C5 he should be able to
equalize the game hash right uh give me
some of the pros to the move A2 A3
because other than maybe playing for
Queen's Gambit accepted style A3 C5
detect C5 Bishop takes C5 I can imagine
as wide I can play before and somehow
justify the move A2 A3 in the opening
when I see a move that doesn't play in
towards the center a2a3 has nothing to
do with the center I just think it's a
bad move
so tell me about the pros
that is supportive of the move A3
because I'm still struggling uh VAR I
think definitely after the move a3e
specifically against the move C5 because
if you play this move now white can
respond with d takes C5 right now you
have to capture because otherwise after
before I can just simply secure that
pawn so you capture back with the bishop
then I play the move B4 so I'm gaining a
little Tempo now you have to you have to
move the bishop now again so Bishop goes
back to E7 and here I can play for
example C4 immediately right uh if you
capture on C4 you're never going to be
really able to secure that pawn because
you don't really have the move B5
because of my Bishop is on this diagonal
right so let's say the game can continue
with A5
B5
Knight bd7
Bishop B2
the idea is to put the Knight only two
and the main problem here is the slide
score Bishop if black can manage to play
the move B6 Bishop B7 Rook C8 he should
have no problems here but it's not so
easy here let's say if you play the move
B6 then actually
and C takes D5 is a possibility
Knight takes D5 and now we see the
problem here of the C6 Square white has
this option to play Knight D4 and then
Knight will go to C6
so this could be a problem here so
that's why you can't really play the
move B6 in this position so you have to
play a move like Knight B6 but it's not
really going to help you with your
development of the bishop on C8 so after
Knight bd2
A4
and Knight a E5 white has a slightly
better position once again because the
bishop is still stuck on C8 here
thank you very much yeah and I want to
say I think the main idea of A3 is the
surprise Factor
your opponent and taking him out of the
opening Theory right okay uh a2a3 boy uh
I do have one question so uh ding did
play Knight D2 and VAR was showing us uh
ideas with E4
then we came up since uh doodle already
played B5 where are you which which I
already liked it's the fourth game yes
there it is since dude already played B5
the move that I like because it doesn't
allow white to play C4 right but there's
one downside right it we can still see
five square true so after Knight D2
which is already on the board Knight C3
A6 now 92 yes could it be possible that
Ding also has an idea to play B4 and
Knight B3
sure
B4 Knight B3 and Knight C5 yeah and uh
sort of sort of like a yeah as Bobby
Fischer said to get squares you got to
give them so black has given the C5
square but he's gotten control of the C4
Square so let's just let's follow that
line and that happened that VAR was
giving us can we do anything you can do
I can do better kind of thing and just
because if black plays nights before I
always have A4 ideas undermining
everything that's going on over there
yeah this gets into a pretty interesting
strategic Channel I
I could I couldn't subscribe I I like I
wanted to bring up the game of Wesley so
again two of our tournament co-leaders
going head-to-head and this what is this
uh particular defense called I I almost
want to subscribe it to uh Sasha
grishock and say it's the grishook you
know English reversed uh but uh I don't
know what what name to give it Bishop C5
D3 H6 Knight takes Bishop takes Bishop
D2 queen queen E6 I don't think I've
seen that
move usually in this type of position
when you want to move the queen it goes
back to d8 it goes back to DEA
yeah
well yeah it depends I I know what
you're saying that the queen is
oftentimes vulnerable in the center of
the board right so you kind of think
okay on d8 it's less chances of being
aggressed
Bishop C3 Rook d8 now I'm thinking what
if white goes Knight D2 right and
tickles the coin again exactly so uh
whenever I see this move Knight D2 I
want to play Bishop H3 as black just
Bishop H3 I love to play Bishop H3 so I
need to get my queen in support of the
H3 Square let's say I shift yeah so it's
pretty clear what I want to do I want to
play bishop and now you can tickle my
knight or pardon me your knight can
tickle my Bishop
or even Pawn on E5 also
can be tickled
it's technically even hanging but
it's
it's not exactly going to win material
but I I hear you I mean there you have
to be paying attention power to play
Knight C4 after Queen G6 Knight to C4
exactly
Knight to C4
okay
um
I gotta defend the pawn on E5 right not
much else to be said for that
Bishop to D4
I None of no games have come up which
means that we we've reached novel uh uh
channels uh in in the position
um
Rook d8 all of this stuff is standard uh
VAR
for the two players not so many games
played in this position Yasser so we can
take a look here only a few games I see
in my database here so the current
position after Rook did only two games
here uh played by one uh one game
between two grand Masters so 92 just
played as you mentioned the idea is to
play Knight E4 and here's block has the
black has few options here Bishop E6 is
of course one option wow but then you
have Knight E4
Queen to f8 or E7
Knight takes C5 Queen takes C5 and looks
like white maybe has a very small
Advantage here it's uh Rook D1 now the
idea is trying to create a rook C1 and
try to put pressure on sofa but here
strangely enough black can just take on
it too
and uh me like the main line goes before
Queen B5 it's very important to prevent
the move B5 otherwise if y can play B5
will open up the diagonal for the bishop
and you can lose the pawn on B7 and
here's Bishop takes
C6
if you take back with the queen after
Bishop takes C5 white is slightly better
Dash and if you take back with the pawn
white can play for example Bishop D2
with the idea to play Rook C5 and it
appears to be maybe white is slightly
better in this position
but of course you don't have to allow
the move Knight E4
in this position but oh Bishop P6 is
actually played already so he's not
really afraid of the move Knight E4 here
so I think we're going to see that
variation after 94 capturing on C5
perhaps white has a very very slightly
better position there
very very slightly better positioned as
we see the head-to-head scores once
again uh Wesley so with two victories to
null uh in their head-to-head uh matchup
uh just checking in on the other
co-leaders games uh that is between Fabi
and nepo uh when we left it we saw this
move Knight to F3 Bishop to E6 simply
defending the pawn on a D5 asking Bobby
what's your scheme of development plan
b2b3 Bishop
um pardon me A6 putting the question to
the bishop and really that's an awkward
question because on the one hand you
want to retain the bishop you want to
play the move Bishop E2 but then the
question is D3 also possible right
exactly I wanted to say that once you
play Bishop E2 say castles Bishop B2
Rook E8 let's say Rook C1 looks C8 the
question is what is your knight doing on
C3 you might have some awkward questions
to add to ask and answer the Knight
can't go to B5 it's not going forward if
it goes backwards which brought up what
you you just said Nasi is maybe retreat
D3 with the idea that in the very near
future after for example castles Bishop
B2 the idea is that you might be able to
play Knight E2 and swing your knight to
a better
square if you want to point out that
Fabiana already has spent about 15 16
minutes
on move 12 so he might be out of the
book
I wouldn't say that he's uh because he's
so gosh darn well prepared I think it's
one of those things where he's really
thinking
you know he's he's most certainly
analyzed Bishop takes Bishop on B5 takes
C6 like that was like a super main
alternative right so he's certainly been
studying the positions after Bishop
takes C6 as well as Bishop D3 and which
one do I want to play which one do I
want to play which one do I want to play
he eventually chose Bishop D3 but by the
way this is again right away nepo uh is
his uh has has been playing
again prep is showing precisely at this
moment after Bishop D3 I think a lot of
us hands in the air very lazily would
have played Castle yes right but nepo is
saying that at this precise moment I
need
play precisely because I know as black
if white gets in Bishop B2 and 92 and
Knight F4 I could play an isolated Queen
Pawn position and not very nice sorry I
think his idea is to exchange the
isolated uh Pawn very fast after let's
say y takes 95. good exactly and then we
play Bishop B2 maybe black can play D4
right away okay and so
well in fact uh I I see games popping up
in the database so
I one of the things that might stop just
for a moment and say well wait a minute
this bishop is not protected I can for
example move and that could be unless
there's a bishop takes uh
to your point of what may be wanting to
trade oh no no uh-huh I wanted to I
wanted to uh to play your move d4 but I
wanted to defend the E5 Bishop with it
gain of a tempo
but I could play at four
yeah but two key battles for the first
place as our tournament co-leaders the
quad
are all playing with one another Wesley
uh right Fabiano's playing uh Nepal and
Wesley's playing Richard exactly
um
nepo playing very very quickly VAR and
he played this move Knight E5 all part
of his prep and I'm thinking it's a very
precise move is it I think so I think so
yes sir and the move A6 actually this is
actually I think what caught Fabi by
surprise perhaps first time in this
tournament because so far he's been
dominating in the opening stage and he
spent a lot of time after the move A6
here let's take a look in this position
so the main move here is actually Castle
so probably Fabi was aware of that there
was a game Carson versus gershuk Carlson
pragananda report hit a game like this
but this A6 is very interesting and you
don't see too many games already after
this only four games in my database and
here's Bishop E2 as you mentioned if you
put a bishop 22 you just don't have a
good way now to improve this Knight you
really need this E2 Square for the
Knight to go to then try to go to D4 or
F4 so that's why I think he didn't play
this move and after Bishop he took
Castle Black is Black is completely fine
there
for example Castle Bishop B2 you can
play here Rook C8 with the idea of Queen
E7 Rook fd8 even though you have
isolated Pawn but I think you're very
comfortable because of this Knight
actually misplaced being misplaced on C3
here so he played Bishop D3 here and
often times we see this idea in this
isolated Pawn tarash slash positions
when the bishop is only two you play
this move now 95 here putting pressure
on the bishop and you don't really want
to give up the bishop here so and if you
Retreat now then you're losing temples
this is actually very bad here
tactically because now there is a move
Queen C7
putting pressure on C3 and now
threatening Knight takes F3 picking up
the pawn on H2 so you cannot play the
movie too you will be in big trouble
here so after 95 you really need to
capture here there is a move 92 but I'm
not sure if Fabi will play this move
because allowing Knight takes F3 GTX F3
Bishop HD that it doesn't look it
doesn't look that good here it doesn't
look healthy at all yeah so you know
even though engine engine thinks it's
just still about equal here but I don't
think he will play like this so after
the move 95 I think we're gonna see
Knight takes E5
Bishop takes E5 now putting pressure on
the Knight on C3 you really forced now
to play the move Bishop B2 to protect
the Knight and here black has a few
options here D4 is a possibility here
immediately or you can just Castle
if you play for example the move like
Queen D6 this could run into a move like
F4 right and then you you don't really
want to allow this because after Bishop
C3 Bishop takes C3 white is going to
have the pair of the bishop this could
be very very strong so you don't want to
play Queen D6 so you have two options
here either D4 or Castle so if you
Castle
and again you have this D4 idea always
in mind it doesn't as a rule when you
have the isolated pawn and you have an
opportunity you should be looking for
this D4 idea here so Queen D2 for
example
could be played again after the move
Queen D2 white wants to play this move
Knight E2 here so let's say if you just
play Rook C8 after Knight E2
Bishop takes B2 Queen Bishop takes B2
Queen B2 white will have a very nice and
a pleasant Advantage here now D5 Pawn is
completely blocked you have Knight F4
ideas and I can go to D4 Rook fd1 you
will have some nice pressure here so
that's why after Queen D2 you have to do
something here instead of the move Rook
C8 so there are some options here with
deforge and also perhaps the move Knight
E4 will give black the equality here
thank you Bart
I want to take a look at this one game
between diak and firuja all right
because I saw that movie too that was a
snap like what they played the slop
defense and then a surprising move of B4
yeah and well right here this is the
main main line stuff and basically after
the move E7 E6 everybody and his brother
plays Knight H4 trying to uh tackle the
light Square Bishop Bishop E2 a little
bit off the Beaten Track okay people
play this move h7h6 so farouza says hey
look if you try to go Knight H4 I'm
ready for you I'll play Bishop H7 and
then after castles Knight D7 Bishop to
D3 after all this bishop on F5 is
actually pretty darn good the bishop on
E2 not so good you kind of this is
always hard to explain why white first
spent a temple on developing Bishop on
E2 right and then spends another one I'm
going Bishop D3 exactly and the crew
direct answer to that question is yes
but I force you to play age six and I go
yeah but I'd like to play H6 well maybe
not maybe not sound somewhere down the
the Broken Road maybe the move H7 H6 is
not as good uh we get to this position
and I simply love this move Bishop
before okay again I kind of revealed
myself like I did like to play the Dutch
stone wall trading off the light squared
Bishops potentially taking control of
the E4 Square after Bishop takes C3
something I would love to do Bishop D2
Bishop A5 I think I would have castled
myself but Bishop A5 and right here
right now
whoa where did that come from like what
the b2b4 uh attacking the bishop like
okay what happens if I take the pawn
well if you take I am assuming we get
that's like Knight takes and you play
Knight takes in order to protect the
bishop I take and now you play Bishop
takes please recapture my Bishop so I
recapture the pawn no I'll take over yes
a suizen zoo so the move b2b4 does not
sacrifice upon uh farusha didn't want to
take it no he immediately he dropped
back with his bishop and after B5 we
caught up with the players the question
for me though is after the move Bishop
D2 let's say
um I take just take yeah you put the
Knight on e4 probably I want to stop
Bishop before I'm not 100 sure but but
yeah and we just play bishop and Knight
versus uh two knights and The Bishop's
fine don't get me wrong you know you
could put your Bishop on B4 you could
play B3 but
the whole thing is I get to play the
light Square we're both Karo Khan
players so I think you can feel a
certain sympathy or uh empathy uh for
this uh line of play
um
for controlling of E4 Square uh this
game what's your first impression it's a
little space a little something for
wider I think before it's a very
interesting idea yeah I like it now
after B5 yes it looks like black hasn't
even finished development yet hasn't it
yet and why it's uh minority attack on
the queen side's already happening yeah
and The Rook whites Rooks are already
um
I'll tell you objectively it should be
equal right it's uh it's looking I would
prefer to be white you would prefer it I
I think so as well I mean uh let's just
imagine after B5 just uh why would I
kind of prefer to be white because after
for example takes takes even if I played
this move and allowed you everything E5
and I go Queen
um
Queen A6 uh I really am very seriously
interested in simply capturing
yeah go Pond hunting and even if I don't
go Pond hunting necessarily like that I
may be dropping in on the seventh rank
with Rook to B1 to B7 so I do see more
uh attacking
possibilities for white so I would be
sympathetic to White I will say black
will also have counter play with E5 E4
and right we'll try to focus on the king
side yeah and very often times too black
does Play Moves Like D takes C4 Queen
take C4 moves the Knight trades and then
ends up with some light squares in the
center of the board VAR what game has
caught uh your eye in uh another one of
those rounds where we're seeing a very
wide variety of openings it's not like
three berlins uh out of five games
absolutely the Yasser some very
interesting games I wanted just to talk
a little bit about this game that you
guys were analyzing so just to show some
of the variations after the move B4
so the point of before is if you just
decide to capture here white has this
very nice movement Knight takes D5 right
and if you take on D2 We have the in
between move Knight takes F6 check and
here you can take back with the queen or
a knight and if we look at this position
after the move Queen D2 here white will
be actually slightly better here because
essentially you traded your B Pawn for
the Central Pawn on D5 so you have a
nice control of the center and open line
with Rook B1 you can try to put some
pressure even here it's a very small
Advantage here black has to play the
move C5 I think it's very important not
to allow white to play the move C5 here
because then there will be some
possibilities putting a knight on D6 so
this is one line white Bishop before
maybe it's not the best and if we go
back uh to this position if you take
back Knight takes D5 because now if you
capture them before there is Knight
takes before why can take on D5 and if
you take Bishop D2 now this actually
really bad now for black here because
you can play
D takes E6 and now attacking the Knight
again the bishop is still hanging on D2
you if you capture back only six just
after 92 white will have a very nice
Advantage so you can play the move
Bishop A5
now we'll take on D7 check Queen takes
D7 and we get this position we're
actually after the move 95 white is
actually much better here because the
king is still in the middle of the board
and you can play the move Rook a B1 and
Rook fc1 to put some more pressure on
the B and C file so that's the reason
why after the move before black played
the move Bishop C7 which is the best
move here and now he is trying to play
the move Knight B6 and try to put the
Knight on C4 white does have some
problems with the light squares here
especially the Bishops already off the
board so there's some weaknesses here
the E4 Square any particular the C4
Square here so the move B5 was played
and here future played the best move
guys Knight B6 here putting pressure on
C4 and now trying to secure that square
for the knight uh on C4 so C5 for
example probably will be played Knight
to C4 B takes C6 B takes C6 and even
though there is a weakness on C6 it'll
be very very hard to attack the spawn
and at some point black will be looking
for some possibilities with E5 here and
here why it doesn't have yasser's Queen
A6 exactly yeah the Knight on C4 uh
block block blocks that uh possibility
so Knight B6 good move yeah and black is
absolutely fine in that position
yeah
and maybe uh Christian uh got one right
as he was saying that this was a big
head-to-head game where he was expecting
that since both players are playing for
the win by the way we did see VAR we did
say see dioc capturing on
um
C6 is there a possibility of sneaking in
a a pawn grab taking on C4 and then
taking back on C6 absolutely yeah sir
you can play D takes uh C4 in this
position right for example now if you
take you know the queen is under attack
so you have to move the queen here you
have two options here you can play Queen
to E2 or queen 2 C2 here right so let's
take a look for example Queen C2 then
black has to recapture here precisely uh
and here white has a few options
position is just equal here you can play
the move Knight A4
with the idea try to exchange the Knight
and pick up the pawn on C4 but in that
case you will be fixing my Pawn
structure so black Castle precisely and
if you go Knight takes B6 make my day
sp6 Queen C4 and actually a very very
nice move I think an important with
Queen D5 here sure trying to trade the
queens and uh you can take back with
even the C Pawn there rook fc1 and here
again once again we see this idea of the
the discovery check very strong tactical
idea so it looks like you have two
attackers on C6 but if you take you're
gonna run into the move Bishop H2
discovery check picking up the queen
here without this move Rook fc8 actually
uh White would have have some serious
Advantage here because there's no good
way to protect the C6 Pawn
thank you for that little one point yeah
there
and uh just to boldly point out the
obvious our number one seed alireza
faruga defending Grand Chester uh
Champion three games one point
that's an understatement yeah I mean
slow start indeed I'm sure his Ambitions
uh he might have been satisfied with two
out of three yeah but uh one out of
three no way I'd like to turn our
attention
to uh the game between mvl and Anish
Gary because when we left it we left it
at the move h2h4 very topical
um scotch and again I always felt that
the move Queen E6 was the proper
response to H4 D7 D6 by Anish certainly
one of many uh possible choices but I
must say that the position
that mvl has achieved I like white and
after the move C4 Knight B6 this is this
is playing into whites hands whenever
I'm able to kick this Knight to what I
want to say is the Lesser Square uh
I feel that black is a a difficult
position after the last move Bishop H3
in the immortal right is present yeah
exactly and in the immortal words of my
uh trainer Nikolai minute gift meet the
poem yes to me the pawn on C6 Bishop
takes C6 I'm assuming Rook C8 and I'm
assuming b2b3
and again if we allow you know you you
better press you better do something
very very concretely and the next few
moves as black because if you give white
all the time he needs to play Bishop E3
Castle's long which is kind of nice
putting the king over there put your
Bishop on D4 the bishop will simply Lord
over the position on the D4 Square both
white Bishops are looking good yeah so
Anish and blocks plus structure is not
ideal and exactly now I see that this is
still uh we're in the throes of theory
uh here as I see we we've got games but
uh VAR isn't this one of those positions
statistically that favors white nicely
absolutely yeah sir white is slightly
better here and again if you give white
few more moves Bishop E3 Castle Rook fd1
Rook ac1 I think it will be just a very
big Advantage here so Anish needs to
play for the quick D5 at some point
without the move D5 he can never
equalize this position here so I think
he will be looking forward to maybe
playing Bishop F6 next castle and he
really needs to get this D5 movement
because D5 will open up the position of
the bishop and also finally will bring
this Knight on B6 into the game here
because with this structure A2 b3c4 the
Knight on B6 is really really misplaced
and very passive but let's take a look
now what white can try to do to try to
make it more difficult for black to play
the move D5 okay so Bishop Bishop E7 and
let's see here so you have two options
you can cancel but again H4 Pawn is
saying so probably he will start with
the move Bishop E3
developing the bishop and here you can
play a castle or even D5 immediately but
most likely let's look at he will play
castle and here white has some options
here for example you have the move Rook
D1 you can start with or you can try to
Castle as well here so let's say Rook D1
putting pressure on D6 rook fd8 and we
see some problem with this H4 Pawn here
because a lot of these lines you
actually have to Castle and just you
know just give up the pawn on uh H4
because black is ready now to play this
move D5 we don't have time for let's say
to play the move H5 because then after
D5 uh black is just equalizing here this
is an important moment in a game here
you don't have that time to play this
move so you can cancel here for example
Bishop takes H4
sacrifice the pawn and then you have
this idea A4 very concrete now because
now you're threatening to play A5 and
attack the Knight on B6 wow and win
either A7 or D6 spawn I guess yes uh so
there is there's actually a line where
you give up a seven pound Bishop E7 A5
now if you go you don't want to go night
eight it will be very bad Bishop takes
A7 so you go Knight D7
and now Bishop takes A7 Rook A8
attacking the bishop
and if the bishop comes back to B6 now
Knight takes B6 a takes B6 you go Rook
AB8
it's it's a very long line it looks like
white might have a small Advantage here
but after D5
it's it's it's not so clear because
black still has a pair of the Bishops
back to you guys
thank you for that uh for a niche is one
of those Pacers you know they get off
certain players get up from the board
and they do a lot of their calculating
while walking on a stage on each
certainly belongs in their category of
Pacers uh by the way we've really been
enjoying your uh questions as you
Channel and challenge our panel easy for
me to say and there's a way for you to
join the conversation right you can
tweet Us by using a hashtag superbetch
has classic or you can send your
questions on our YouTube channel or
Twitter Channel at Saint Lucia's Club
absolutely I'm looking at the game of
Richard Rapport versus Wesley so again
where all of our four co-leaders are
clashing head to head I'm looking at
this move
a2a4 and I'm kind of a little bit
questioning that move uh many times when
I'm white and in these englishes and
I've been white in these englishes like
my entire career I've always aspired to
be playing the moves B4 and B5 so
normally speaking I'm playing the move
A3 as a preparatory move to being able
to play B4 and B5 and I've always issued
avoided playing a move like A4 because
if my opponent plays A5 and I'm not
saying A5 is the best movie or anything
like that it just could put the kibosh
right on my whole B4 uh B5 plans I'm
never going to get that in maybe in this
case I'm going to play for Knight C4 but
okay that's a different kettle of fish
and
um I actually like A5 right here you do
you do and I'm just saying that yeah
that you know I I won a square so to
speak but black has two uh black has
these especially the D4 Square I think
it played and he did play it
let's uh throw the ball to Christian in
Bucharest
thank you Yasser just to give you guys
an update on what's happening in the
game between Fabiano caruano with white
pieces and Jana ponyashi with the black
pieces uh before the round started I
have to say I was looking at the energy
of uh the players and you know I said at
the beginning of the show that Jan
probably is a bit disappointed about the
missed chance yesterday in his game
against dingley Wren but
um he wasn't showing it he looked very
relaxed he was looking ready for a
battle and let's not forget he's coming
up from a world championship match his
preparation right now is at the highest
level and despite the fact that dingley
ran for the majority of the match played
the move E4 so Jan didn't have to show
what his preparation was against one D4
you know that he has something in the
back and this is exactly what's
happening right now he's showing
residual preparation from his world
championship match and in fact let's
take a look at the big moment in the
early stages of at this game after the
move A6 by Ayan and by the way up to
this point up to the move A6 Fabiano has
spent one hour has spent absolutely no
time he had one hour and 34 minutes on
his clock so he gained the time he was
definitely showing that he's ready for
this variation the same with nepo nepo
did not spend uh any minutes on his
clock either but after the move A6 for
the next move Fabiano spent almost 20
minutes he played the move Bishop to D3
the obvious alternative is to take on C6
and change the structure in the position
now there are some interesting ideas
behind this change of structure but it
simply just doesn't work for white
because black after night wave or for
example you need to focus by the way on
the Square C5 you have uh to take
control of the square C5 if you can in
time the problem is that white just
simply is not in time for example Castle
Bishop to B2 give me one more move for
example Rook to E8 and I will play Rook
to C1 I will follow that up with Knight
to C5 and I will take control of the
dark squares on the queen side which is
going to give me a tremendous
strategical Advantage but what black can
do instead of Rook to E8 for example is
to immediately uh take the full center
with the move C5 and now we have the
hanging pawns but the thing is this
position and the hanging pawns are in
the center on the C and D files are
extremely well protected for black the
bishop 26 the Knight on F6 is doing a
tremendous job you have very good Bishop
on B2 but you don't have any Targets as
white and I will just simply develop my
pieces behind those hanging pawns and
your pieces as wide they're just not on
their ideal squares so this would
actually give black quite significant
Advantage chances in this game that's
why Fabiano after a long day think
played the move Bishop to D3 dropping
back with the bishop Knight to E5 came
immediately from janso he was definitely
still within his preparation this is
what I'm talking about this is
preparation for the world championship
match 965 Bishop takes C5 Bishop to B2
and by the way
right now Jan has thought for a very
long time and he just made a move that I
did not anticipate I was just about uh
to give a monologue about why is he
thinking why is he just simply not
playing the move short Castle because
short Castle is by far and the only move
that has been played in this position
and right now Queen to D2 this is the
critical position in the game you have
to know this move or you have to
calculate this move Knight to E4 if you
give me one more move as white I will
get a not decisive but quite a
significant lead in a strategical play
for why for example if you play the move
Rook to C8 I just simply drop back and
now we can see the idea behind this move
Queen to D to defend the bishop on B2
and if we do exchange these two Bishops
well you're going to have huge problems
because of your isolated Queen's Pawn on
D5 you don't have any attacking
capabilities on the king side as black
so right now you're in trouble you
cannot allow me to exchange these
Bishops after the move Queen to D2
that's why you have to play the move
Knight to E4 if you know this you're
most likely going to equalize the
position quite easily Knight takes C4
take on e4 take on
um E5 and now I have a couple of options
as black but we see the presence of the
opposite uh color Bishops on the board
limited material there's no imbalances
in the structure I can take with the
queen for example and this is just going
to lead to a very uh equal position Jan
decided to play Rook to C8 is this
signaling the fact that he wants more
from this position perhaps he wants to
play for an advantage but now I will
just simply go Queen to D2 I'm trying to
understand what his idea is he can go
Castle but once again this transposes to
what I said shouldn't be Jan's
preference in this game because of
Knight to E2 and strategic problems for
a black in this position so after for
example Queen to D2 let's just go back
to the game
after Queen to D2 not Castle Rook to C8
Queen to D2 Knight to E4 is an option
once again but this is a slightly
different situation because you don't
have Castle on the board so what's the
consequence of that well your G7 Pawn is
not protected you cannot take for
example on e4 take on E5 and now
recapture on D3 because
the G7 Pawn is unprotected I will snatch
that off the board and that's going to
give me a tremendous Advantage so I'm
looking at the position of the Rook to
C8 sure I understand it's still within
margins of equality but after Queen to
D2 maybe perhaps you know Jan is taking
a slight misstep in this position still
very balanced still is going to be very
difficult for Fabiano to get his first
victory in classical chess against yarn
nepomyoshi but definitely an intriguing
battle ahead in this close matchup guys
back to you thank you Chris and some
subtleties there in that game of the uh
worth investigating I just saw that the
mvl is trying to make use of his H4 Pawn
instead of the engine prescribed move of
Bishop E3
as pointed out by by virusian by VAR
um
MBL said look I put my Pawn on the H4 or
let me justify my earlier play if you
want to take on G5 Bishop takes G5 H to
hg5 you might be doing me a favor
yeah I could on a on a good day castle
and maybe play Rook H4 and who knows put
pressure on the H7 Pawn but if you
if you have to play F7 F6 then the move
Bishop G5 is really fully Justified
because in this case you just put your
Pawn on F6 and you're no longer yeah you
don't like this you've undermined your
Bishop on E6 so is there a way for Anish
to take advantage what about what about
it's age six H6 okay same ideas F6 but
better version right all right yeah then
we then we're going to trade trade and
maybe
you know uh there was this old guy you
know uh Jose Raul capablanca and he uh
like many world champions gave the world
an insight to chess and one of the
things that Kappa Blanca said was Pawn
Islands
he always talked about Pawn islands and
he said whoever has the most Pawn
Islands stands Worse full stop so in
this position you could talk about white
as having two Pawn Islands the F2 G2 H4
is being one Pawn Island a group of
Pawns the A2 to C4 being another group
of ponds but then you look across the
board and you say well black has three
Bingo and even though you know it's one
of those things that's kind of subtle
and you've got a lot to prove
yeah I mean Kappa Blanca did have a
point after Rook dt4 Rook to D1 uh
somehow the isolated Pawn on A7 can turn
out to be weakness
play very uh carefully here maybe play
D5 right away right away okay to get rid
of some fun Islands
yes okay and I got it obviously you're
frightening me I gotta I gotta step off
the we have an update in the game Anish
played D5 without H6
oh okay things are definitely heating up
and just as we were getting ready to go
on our first break of the day uh no H6
no F6
immediate D5
well is there is that a connection is
that a logic connection there that you
Play Bishop E7 and then D5
maybe he was not expecting Bishop G5 and
if white played Bishop B3 he was
prepared to play D5 anyways okay so he
decided to play D5 here too because he's
not afraid of Bishop takes E7 that won't
change anything for black okay so Bishop
logical D5 okay
I'll I'll play ball okay we take King
takes yeah
I'll take maybe you can take with the
Knight take with the Knight okay well
then I do simply have split pawns and
this is just going to be a long-term
event it's going to try to exchange
everything Knight C3 and Bishop D5
yeah equalize as fast as possible and uh
no in the words of somebody uh famous
you're just gonna suffer
you'll suffer for a long time you've got
these uh split pawns on the on the um uh
Queen side to deal with I don't know
Vara what do you what do you think of oh
actually you have the other game in
front of you uh what are you looking
good for yeah well that came you guys
were talking about you cover most of the
ideas it's just it's very very slightly
better for white but I think Bishop G5
the main difference for that game is
with the bishop on G5 uh if you had a
bush Bishop on E3 it allow you the A4 A5
Plum but without the Bishops you don't
have that idea but there is a very nice
trick in this position I know you guys
were analyzing this and you were
thinking about the move Knight C4 here
but here black is a very very pretty
tactic here Bishop takes E4
D takes C4 and Bishop takes F2 check
so you cannot take with the Rook because
you're gonna lose an exchange after
Queen takes D1 Rook takes D1 now you're
losing an exchange
uh Rook takes D1 and if you take back
with the King then actually
King to a queen to C5 check and black is
going to pick up the queen on D1 so
white needs to be careful that's why I
think we haven't seen the move here I
like this move a A5 fixing the the white
Pawn here not allowing any A5 advances
and also securing the B4 code so I think
perhaps here now Rapport realizes he
cannot play the move Knight C4 and it's
not so clear how he can continue because
if you don't play Knight C4 that means
you don't have a way to get rid of this
bishop or this bishop and both of these
Bishops are well placed here and I think
Wesley is pretty happy after the opening
outcome here again once again he's been
very very solid and getting really good
positions out of the opening that Knight
C4 Bishop takes F2 that's one of the
nicest traps I've seen in a long time
because it's one of those moves that
comes out of nowhere Bishop takes F2
check with that beautiful queen C5 thank
you for that bar that's a nice trap
indeed as we get ready for our first
break uh let's uh tell
um you what the good Folks at Q Boutique
have this is a premier roll-up vinyl
board it's really really nice features
the World Chess Hall of Fame logos in
the corner
I don't know if you can see that I'll
put it up oh
in in on the corner squares uh very very
very nice uh for those of you tournament
aficionados who like uh to take your
sets with you
and uh
easy packaging easy storing so uh go
check out Q Boutique stl.com and secure
your
Premier roll-up board as we go on break
we have a feature to share and I think
everybody has this question how do you
recover from a very very long classical
game well let's ask the players and see
their answers
foreign
[Music]
this tournament is very long and very
taxing physically how important is it
for you to relax and re-energize after
each and every game the games are
extremitiring of course as we as we go
with the tournament it gets more and
more tiring and also there's lots of
emotions and lots of physical exhaustion
basically So eventually you're going to
run out of energy from from every
possible aspects and then you're just
going to be looking that I think the
best players are the ones who who can
cope with this situation or basically
the original situation as late as
possible in the tournament or who can
cope with it the best and to come on
over their way through the fatigue and
the bunch of errors that will eventually
creep in and um and they can bounce back
quickly it's important if you think
differently see my games from the match
yeah of course learn to rest after long
and top championship match
I didn't expect it to so tough than I
expected but well out today after the
opening ceremony I think I was
uh get into the
tournament I'm ready for tomorrow's game
yeah I think very important to say it's
at least half of what the most important
thing you need to do during retirement
you need confidence and a lot of rest a
lot of sleep your brain cannot function
without getting a good night's rest so
you have to balance it with preparation
during dormant a lot of things can
happen mistakes happen uh so you kind of
need to be ready to speak moments yeah I
think classical chess is the only format
where you have just one game to prepare
for and that really makes a difference
because you can focus on the particular
player or the particular color and bring
your best ideas and have the time to
work them out and get them into your
system so I think that's that's quite
exciting and uh
You know despite the rapid and place
catching on you still see what class
conscious has to offer and uh kind of
spectacular games we see yeah for me
sleeping is very important you should
have a sleep at least eight nine hours
because if you will play for six seven
hours so you have to have a lot of rest
if you're tired you cannot mentally be
ready and think
so it's very important physically also
and maintenance
now definitely I
prioritizing after the games you know
getting some rest and getting ready for
the next games and obviously I'm also
doing that on a daily level
with
physical Sports and trying to increase
my my stamina and such to to be ready
for tournaments that are you know tough
and quite exhaustic okay
rest time it's important probably for
every player because they need some rest
and to prepare for the next stop I think
it's almost like the second most
important after just playing good chess
yeah sometimes you you know there are of
course strong emotions involved in the
guns and you have to you have to recover
sometimes you have to you know forget
about the lost game
I think we saw from a match that when
when people get tired they're you know
they're starting to make decisions that
are atypical of them
they they make mistakes that they
normally wouldn't make so stress and
tiredness that can really play a huge
role in terms of lowering your quality
or like those critical moments you know
and especially when you're low on time
and sometimes you you have to like
switch to Instinct and you just need
like your full capacity so if if you're
a bit tired if you're a bit stressed
these things they you might not even
realize it but they really can play a
huge role
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
welcome back to our live coverage of the
super bet chess classic here are current
standings all right let's take a look at
our standings we have four leaders
Fabiano caruana Yani pomichi Wesley so
and Richard rapper they're all facing
each other today absolutely and then
with 50 we have Champ world champion
Ding liren and anushkiri and trying to
catch up in the tournament fairuzia and
VL Duda and diag nice and as we just
jump uh into the rounds we can see these
these head-to-head matchups that you
just talked about Richard Rapport what
say so two of our co-leaders facing off
as well as Fabi and Neville right
all right as we jump into uh the round I
there's some let's call it controversy
going on here I really think that MBL
has a what I would call long-term
advantage and it's just so much easier
to play White whereas the chess engines
kind of say you got nothing to be proud
of and I'm sitting there you know like
you know pounding the table and say no
it's not true it's not true I actually
have some serious Advantage your your
thought is it serious chess engines are
always taking our excitement away I know
right and the Mystery as well like do
you do you think white has a serious
Advantage serious now but a tiny bit
Advantage it's more pleasant position
but I think it's closer to equality wow
VAR Jump Right In uh tiny or serious no
very very small Advantage if any
advantage actually even that yeah I I
would say for sure I would I would would
pick white nine out of 10. yeah there's
still some Dynamics here and you're like
a one or two moves away yaser here just
from having that nice grip on a position
right and we can check some of the lines
here to see why and so after Bishop E7
played here again uh perhaps this bishop
G5 Bishop E7 maneuver here we were uh
you know we're thinking the bishop E3
would have been a better choice here to
have this bishop on a strong diagonal
here with this A4 um A4 A5 idea but he
played Bishop G5 here and it now the
game continued with D5 Knight takes D5
Bishop takes E7 so now King takes E7
will be played and the if you play the
move Knight E4 here with idea to put a
knight on C5 then black should play the
move C5 here and then C4 another option
here would be to play the move Knight
before here so most likely I think we're
gonna see the move Bishop D5 played and
when I was looking at this position I
thought after CD King D2 if white can
get the Knight E2 94 he should have some
Advantage but even even that position it
doesn't look like that much here let's
say Rook C5
Knight E2 King is very well placed on D6
and every time you put a knight on D4
black can simply just play the move
Bishop D7 now restricting the squares of
the Knight and also play the move A5
next and it's going to be very difficult
to make much progress here let's say
Rook hc1 I can play A5 and very hard to
get this A3 before idea going as well so
and computer shows uh zero zero zero
here
wow uh intriguing I wasn't looking at
the move Bishop takes D5 though VAR I
was looking more at the move Rook C1
okay let's take a look a rook a rook C1
here yeah okay let's see Rook C1 and
here
um a few different ways black can
continue Knight before is one idea but
even just simple capture Knight takes C3
Rook takes it and a very important move
now C5 again just in time to trying to
play this move C4 here right and in
order to prevent that you have to play
Bishop E2 perhaps to control the C4
square and then Rook hd8 we see black
has really good development now here
will be very hard to get a grip on the
position here exactly
so and that's not only only move here in
93 you also have the move Knight before
here as well too if you want to keep
some pieces on the board night before
and look hd8 as well
all right uh those computers there's
pesky computers let's just jump into the
game of fobby and nepo for a moment
because this game between these uh well
uh current leaders current leaders uh
it's the it's the kind of clash that I
like I mean
um the Strategic battles this battles of
ideas and when you look at the position
you kind of think to yourself okay it's
pretty balanced uh black should be happy
until you see the move f2f4 and then you
sort of like well I'm not 100 sure
because uh you you most certainly don't
want to play into the Bishops the the
two Bishops because I'm just thinking
yeah
yeah you can put a knight on e4 but I
just really like this uh the lord of the
board if you will this bishop lording
over things in the center of the board
and if you go back with your Bishop I
don't care we're going to put it back on
B8 yeah if you could if you could put it
here on a good day everything's looking
really good then you kind of like well
just a second
um
four of five is one possibility but
we've always been looking at this idea
of bringing the Knight to D4 as well as
you know this bishop and you start to
yeah yeah you start to feel that maybe
white has a little something in the
position in the move F4 has a stop uh
nepo yeah which is you know like like
that that's a victory in and of itself
the fact that you know nepo's not pacing
and he's actually at the board thinking
and the move F4 is a challenge for what
is going on in nepo's mind facing the
move F4
actually F4 is the best move yes sir
because it's also a very necessary move
to play because there is no good way now
to prevent the black from playing the
move d4 here and completely equalize the
game here for example we can check the
move with if you play Queen D2 in this
position if you don't play the move F4
if you are afraid you think it's a
weakening move you play the move Queen
D2 then simply D4 it just immediately
equalizes the game you no longer have an
id2 idea because now D takes E3 will be
attacking your queen and then you're
losing a piece actually in this line so
after D4 you you can capture here but as
we know oftentimes when I play D4 and
let's say capture back it simplifies the
position it's going to be pretty much
impossible to claim any kind of
Advantage here for White Knight A4 Queen
F4 here Queens will come off the board
next and uh and Position will simply
simplify and black no longer has that
isolated Pawn on B5 here so I think F4
move is a is a very precise move it's a
very challenging move and it shows that
Fabiano is still trying to play for a
win here but position is equal here
Bishop B8 is one option I know you were
looking at that Bishop D6 is another
move that is playable here with idea to
control this diagonal perhaps to play
Bishop C5 at some point so Knight E2
right makes a lot of sense and now Queen
to E7 here Queen is very well placed in
this position on E7 because first of all
you're connecting your Rooks you have
some options with Bishop A3 I think you
would be okay with exchanging this B2
Bishop here and also at some point
you're applying pressure only three as
well here so the line can continue with
H3 here Bishop D7 for example putting
pressure only three here
Bishop D4
Rook takes C1 Queen takes C1 Rook C8
attacking a queen and after Queen B2
there are options like Bishop A3 Bishop
C5 as well with the pawn on E3 they're
always going to be some Contra play
because it's weak here so that's why
black is absolutely fine in this
position
thank you uh VAR for that a game that
kind of slipped away from us a little
bit uh ding lyron versus Duda I'll go
back to this position where A3 and
Knight C3 and B5 this B7 B5 especially
is an anti-catalan weapon I have a
certain sympathy for it I must say and
after a692 now why did I go back so far
because we've got a lot to go ahead
because it's almost like everything that
happens from here on out is a very
forcing clear path the move Knight D2
has a singular purpose we're going to
play the move E2 E4 which Duda allowed
he played Knight E7 E4 and all of these
moves came pretty much forcing there was
a trade on F6 there was a trade on B7
Queen F3 so it all looks as if white has
a certain Advantage after all he's the
first to connect his Rooks he's made the
break in the center and he's flexing
this and he's doing that and you're all
gung-ho yeah it's interesting even
without the C for the position still
looks very much Catalan type of position
for white yeah but
there's really nothing that wrong with
Black's position either at this current
moment the only thing is is a sapon on
C7 which we can defend and there's lots
of ways of Defending it in fact if we
were reach into the position and
withdraw
subtract the C2 upon and the C7 Pawn we
say black is fine it's an isolated Queen
pawn and nothing could be done so
everything that white has done since
a2a3 he's achieved the question is has
he achieved anything at all Queen D7
Bishop E5 Rook d8 Rook D1 and here it
comes he's planning to play D5
eventually possibly possibly uh taking
advantage of the fact that he's maybe
more harmoniously developed in the
center but here it comes Knight D5 that
is a kind of an in-your-face kind of
move I just you don't want to trade on
D5 if you were winning a pawn it would
be everything that we would want to do
right we would be very very happy until
we see the move Rook C6 and oops
nobody's interested in trading off the
C7 pawns so the move Knight D5 is a
rather in your face kind of move because
if you're if you allow black to follow
up the move Knight D5 with Rook C6 he's
absolutely fine so do you see some
Advantage for ding because at the moment
I wanted to play 94 but yes you
mentioned Rook C6 still looks good even
after 94. right away right
94 Rook C6 I absolutely agree with you I
also somehow that Fabiano game where I
played F5 here I kind of played F6 you
know white spent time going Bishop C
wand F4 to E5
and he's gonna go backwards right now
he's just he's just he's just going to
go backwards but your point of Rook C6
is well made
maybe Queen C6 something to be said for
Queen C6 as well so at the moment I
think that dude has just been rolling
with all the punches and he's not
unhappy there is one idea there guys
sorry for Interruption
actually 95 perhaps 95 is actually very
slightly inaccurate here really Queen C6
was I think a better try here because of
this idea if you play Knight D5 which
you already did white must take on D5 in
order to obtain any kind of Advantage
here if you play Knight E4 Rook C6 as
you mentioned black is doing absolutely
fine during the night is well placed and
you're never really going to be able to
play the C4 the it's going to take you a
long time so the point here is Knight
takes D5 Queen takes D5 which you were
looking at the answer Queen G4 but there
is this move Queen G4 not putting
pressure on G6 forcing you to play F6 or
G6 and in this case actually you have
the bishop C7 yeah winning so this
actually makes a big difference because
now you're going to be forced to take
back with a pawn right on D5 and in that
case I stand white has a small Plus in
this position because the Rooks are not
very well placed if they were on a
background you already had a rook on the
e-file you would be able to
easily equalize here still there are
some some ideas here for example the
move Bishop F4 he can start with here
and try to control the e-file here so
you you need some moves here to organize
your defense here you have some
weaknesses on C7 on D5 if you play a
move like C6 it's going to be hard to
bring the Rook back on V8 here for
example so here Bishop f8 can be played
and now white can play Rook D3
with idea to bring the Rook to E3 here
try to get the control of the e-file
again you don't have rookie 6 because I
can capture and then you have the
problem with the C7 pawn and you don't
really want to take back with the pawn
here because then you're gonna have a
permanent weakness here and there will
be a lot of pressure against that pawn
so it's not so easy here to stabilize
the position here so that's why I think
it's very important for dingler in here
to play the move Knight takes D5 he will
have a very small Advantage here but
black needs to be very very accurate to
try to equalize thank you for that or
and our challenge to our viewers is
coming to fruition as we have our first
uh tweets from social media
and this one is from rafalo Snoop snook
at YouTube right the question is what do
you think about adding chess 960
tournament classical rapid as a
granchester event I love it seriously I
love chess 960. I think it just brings a
completely different Dynamic you just
take all of this opening preparation and
say you know forget about that just play
chess yes exactly I love our uh
Fisher Showdown here that we do
960. uh yeah and I think the players
enjoy it too it's a it's a kind of a
holiday from their preparations right
they don't wake up in the morning the
first thing they do is turn on their
computer and say let me remember my my
uh files but that is coming up it will
happen in September
but as far as a whole as holding a grand
chest Tour event if you have some
sponsors in mind uh let uh do send them
along because we'll be happy and further
tweets
this one is from Stan
the swim man
and the question is I still I still
can't figure out is there a luck factor
in chess or is it only the case of
someone making the mistake another
waiting to give a kiss to casparo but
yes sir once said right uh
it's a very good question and
unfortunately yes there is a luck factor
and no there isn't a luck Factor chess
is one of those games where you know
open cards you know so there shouldn't
be anything like luck in chess but it
happens all the time and uh one of those
moments that you feel like oh I've been
really lucky is when somebody walks head
long into your preparation right it's
just like you you have this beautiful
setup I prepared it for for for VAR but
Christian is my Victim right so there's
that luck when your preparation is right
on somebody walks right into uh
something that that you've prepared and
that exists that there's just no nothing
around it what about you what do you
think about luck in chess you feel lucky
I would also say that when we do the
drawings of pairings
if you get more white pieces that's a
big advantage in tournaments like this
exactly some black factor I think VAR
can talk to that as well sometimes you
have a particular opponent just one
particular guy or gal where you like
lose five games and you draw a five like
but you only lose when you have the
black pieces and you get paired in the
tournament where you have white and
suddenly you have this kind of
confidence well now I don't have to lose
to the guy who's always killing me uh
VAR luck in chess absolutely there is
some luck in chess and getting that
crucial breakthrough I think is very
important to win any big tournaments
like for example myself I was very close
a few times to win the US Championship I
just couldn't finish it just that Final
Touch wasn't there and speaking about
the particular opponents like for
example for many years I was struggling
against gotta kamsky I always had the
black pieces I would play the French
defense it was a big fight but somehow
how he would get the better of it and
finally I managed to win with black in a
French defense in the 2017 U.S
championship by uh just turning it
around and just being a little bit more
confident in my abilities to finally win
against him yeah and uh so luck and then
other times you feel there's no luck in
chess like your opponent was just
playing really well got all of the
answers and there's nothing nothing
there
and one more uh challenge to this one is
from a Jeremy Jesse from YouTube who
asks do you think it's worth the effort
for someone ranked 1000 to study Queen's
Gambit Theory or is it too much to study
seriously first of all all study is good
end of story regardless whether it's you
studying your tactics or you're studying
your end games all study is good
um where you're at at a thousand I
wouldn't suggest that your your opening
Theory should be your target I would
suggest end games end games are like
cheating you're gonna get into end games
you might as well know them inside and
out when you're only a thousand it means
that you still have a lot a lot of
endgame work to iron out so iron out
your endings and those your knowledge of
your endings are going to lead you to
the type of openings that you'll find
attractive because there's certain end
games that you really like to play like
you liked you know these these
formations end game formations where
your Pawn chain seems to extend across
the board you might find yourself self
discover yourself to be a natural-born
French defense player because in a lot
of French defenses you get these engaged
Pawn structures that go all the way
across the board so study your end games
it might lead you hopefully to find your
favorite openings how about you for
Jeremy there got some suggestions I
completely agree with you yes sir oh you
heard just oh you're just so smart
uh yes I think at level 1000 even 1500
and higher exactly your focus shouldn't
be mainly on the openings no if you know
the main ideas in the opening which is
try to control the center develop pieces
and Castle it should be enough and you
should focus on working on your
calculating skills how to you know doing
tactics a lot of tactics and cannot
emphasize this enough in games if you're
good at end games you're going to
improve your rating so fast exactly that
was my strategy when I was young me too
I I was lucky I had a good coach who was
mostly working with me on end games so
my goal was in almost every game to
quickly exchange queens and get to the
end game where I knew General ideas and
my opponents didn't right yeah coach
jumped in with some suggestions for
Jeremy I absolutely agree with whatever
everything you say guys and I in
particular when I get let's say some new
students around that level the first
thing I have this file of about 20
months you must know endgame positions
just to make sure to cover some King
opponent game bishoping games Rook end
games just make sure you know your base
Basics and games first and then I would
recommend do tactics daily to get better
and then at the end also spend a little
bit of time studying openings but
definitely improving your end games will
be a big factor to to get better at
chess and to doing lots of lots of
tactics well VAR could I put you on the
spot for just a moment there because I
think what you said was really really
important that you have in your
files your your you you for your
students you work them and you say
you guys gals you need to have these 20
endings have you put that out on the
internet somewhere and said to folks
these are the 20 endings that you really
should know inside and out and people
look whether it be a video or whatever
I've done some YouTube videos for the
Saint Louis Tesla where I cover some of
this position but it wasn't like a
particular course where I show all these
positions right usually if people won't
take some private lessons I show them
all these positions maybe lesson one or
two I go over this uh important endgame
positions with them exactly so 20 and I
know there was this it was very nice I
think it was John Bartholomew who had
said something like there's a 100 end
games there's a book a hundred end games
and Magnus Carlson had been put on the
spot and said okay what about this on it
oh yeah this is a famous Bishop ending
and I'm supposed to do this in that
Magnus did really really really really
good as you would expect but it was his
intimate
knowledge of end games that just really
stood out and yeah there are certain
ones I want to talk about endings for a
moment I want to turn our attention to
the game between MBL and unleash Gary
because again we had kind of debated the
point of whether White had anything or
not and I was trying to make the
argument not very compellingly I must
say that I really like white because of
the
split pawns and after Bishop takes D5
Bishop takes D5 and you should have
taken with a Pawn on D5 I didn't
understand this bishop takes D5 either I
thought that it was all about this and
uh VAR was explaining that in the
position where white tries to bring the
Knight to D4 it's very important that
the king ended up on D6 The Rook went to
C5 the pawn went to A5 and the engines
were just showing zeros right across the
board Bishop takes D5 that might have
been just frankly an inaccuracy and
after the move castles I think Anish was
thinking was picking up a Tempo against
the pawn on G2 simply not true you do
not want to invite Rook G1 and a
recapture right why are you inviting me
into your camp with Rook takes G7 so the
move castles now this is starting to get
a little awkward because if I'm white
I'm starting to think well maybe I can
take this and even though
I'm giving you a pass Pawn I've got it
really firmly blockaded it uh I've got
Rook that's how you want to check by me
that would be a weak password exactly it
may be more of a liability of an asset
there's even a possibility that the King
which a moment ago was going to be
really secure on D6 it suddenly Exposed
on these open uh files so mvl uh with
the move castles a bit of an advantage
once again let's jump to the games
between our tournament co-leaders and
we'll we'll kick off with the game
between Richard Rapport and uh Wesley so
when we left it we left it right in his
position and this is one of the most
beautiful traps I've seen in quite a
while because it's really a bolt from
the blue Wes pardon me Richard
had played the move a2a4 and after a7a5
stopped yeah it was like oops
Yeah the move A4 was played
in anticipation of being able to play
Knight C4
but VAR pointed out this really
beautiful tactic which when Bishop takes
Pawn takes here comes the reveal uh and
it's right here where white looks fine
like you know what's the problem spoiler
alert yeah to do a puzzle pause right
here exactly uh Bishop takes F2 cabang
uh the queen needs the protection of the
Rook so you can't take King takes walks
into a discover check costing the queen
so literally you have to move your king
and acquiesce to the loss of a pawn with
check
recognizing oops that is to say Richard
recognizing that he cannot play the move
Knight C4 kind of improvised with the
move Queen C2 Bishop D5 Bishop takes D5
Queen B3 Knight D4 and this has been
well known
for decades and decades I think
more or less I'm going to say Anatoly
carpa but I'm sure it predates him
whenever there was a Pawn on D4 versus a
Pawn on E2 the backward the weak Pawn on
E2 is more vulnerable than the pawn on
C7 and these structures have been known
to be better for black for quite a long
while and already uh Wesley you were
talking about that on the opening of the
show uh Wesley it seems like in all of
his games he's slightly better he could
have had more points he could have had
more points for and he's done it again I
mean we're 18 moves or whatever into the
position and blacks for choice but I
will point out one thing please if we
didn't have minor pieces in this
position I would agree that Black's
position is preferable right but we do
have a knight versus Bishop exactly I'm
not loving Black's Bishop 1v6 that's
true you know it's a bad Bishop except
for one thing again I'll point out that
the pawn is on A4 so imagine that this
ugly black Bishop were on B4
and there was a Pawn on C6 then I would
double on the E file and everything
everything again there was this I had uh
a bishop at night Bishop on G2 Bishop on
E6 against Michael talte uh and there
was this bad Bishop the bad dark-square
Bishop but tall was better because he
had the same structure in our game
um with that dark squared Bishop so for
example white to move here I believe
it's white to move yes okay I exchanged
the coins all right 25 and we'll take C5
let's play Rook C2 let's play Rook C2
okay let's play C6
from putting your Bishop on B4 but can I
I don't think so uh I mean what you know
whether it takes me you know a long
while or a short while to put my Bishop
on B4 I think I'm going to Anchor it
there
and the problem is that even if you were
to somehow manage to play e2e3
you want to achieve yeah then D3 would
become a weakness exactly so for the
from from a long-term perspective uh the
the bottom line is that white is going
to be nursing this Pawn on E2 for quite
the while now again this Pawn on A4
really makes this kind of a strange
impression it wouldn't be like like okay
let's just play another move for white
yes if you don't mind we'll just play
this this and again we're just gonna
whoops we shouldn't put our Knight on C4
and now we'll put our Knight here and
suddenly we can understand what black is
trying to achieve he's trying to put his
Rook his Bishop on B4
it feels like the momentum is on on his
side also I've had these positions as
white
where I very cleverly thought to myself
aha I'm so clever
the Rooks are going to be doubled on the
e-file let me plug up the E file with my
knight but as soon as I play Knight E4 I
know you're going to play F5 right so
I'll prepare with G4 and eventually get
my knight D4 a little bit because
usually what my opponents did very very
very slowly they would put a rook on E6
and then they would play G6
and they were playing for F5
um long term it feels like Wesley has an
advantage uh VAR and maybe again the
engines are laughing and saying No it
should be even it should be even don't
you get the impression that you much
rather play Wesley's position
it's it's it's hard to tell I think um
if he can get a bishop on before as you
mentioned yesterday yes definitely I
like the the black's position but I
think most of these lines you guys were
analyzing white puts the Knight on B3
just to specifically discourage that
from happening and put pressure on A5
and the D4 Pawn here so we can take a
look at some of the of the lines here
after the move Rook C2 so here for
example black also has the option it's a
little bit strange here but actually you
can play a move like Queen F5 here
at some point you're looking for some
maybe Queen H3 ideas and let's say
Knight C4 which is a very logical move
try to put pressure and here you play
the move Queen E6 now you're pinning the
coin here and you cannot take on uh B6
if you play a move like Queen B5 then
you're gonna run into a very unpleasant
move Rook D5 right and some potential
ideas with Rook H5 and queen H3 here so
and here you're pinned now and it's not
so clear what can you do here to get out
of this pin for example you play Queen
A3
Rook D5 now with that same idea Bishop
C5 Bishop B4 black will be very happy to
put a bishop on before because it will
be very well placed here blockading all
the Contra play on The Queen side but
also very important controlling the E1
Square which is going to take away the
defensive ideas such as rookie one here
so here you already have to play for
before here which is which is very
logical to try to open the position but
it looks it looks risky yes sir Rook
goes on H5 right and then you have to
worry about the queen H3 move coming in
here seriously so block has the option
here to even keep the Queens on the
board with the move Queen F5 in this
position
nice
huh I wasn't thinking of the Queen's uh
staying on the board at all but uh that
idea of Rook D5 to H5 Queen H3 kind of
scary yeah that sun Shivers up my spine
that looks very very dangerous a game
that kind of slipped away from us it was
a game that uh Christian said he was
going to keep his eyes on uh diac as
white versus uh Ali razor ferrugia and
then here we were kind of thinking that
there was going to be a captures on B6
and it captures on C4 somehow I think we
were leaving The Rook on A1 in that
position just captures captures and it
was going to be close to equality thanks
to the tactical defense of the C6 Pawn
they look had a completely different
idea altogether he played Bishop B4 Rook
B8 Knight B2 he wants to take the pawn
on his terms and maintain this uh split
pawns but farooch is saying wait a
minute are you sure about what you're
doing I'm going to play the move A5 and
suddenly a dayach went into a think here
as this move wasn't really kind of uh
expected uh I want to put it that way uh
why is he gone into a deep tank yeah
choosing between retreating Bishop back
to A3 okay or go into D2
between these guys C5 I guess they're
all options that's the problem is Bishop
E7 an option as well oh my goodness I
didn't even I saw Bishop C5 and I was
thinking that he was he was having a a
pause here because there is a a move C3
that might like for example if we play
Bishop C5 and we just play Just for
arguing the sake because this move C3
right and we've got this discovery right
and white says no no no no I've got this
really great idea I'm gonna play Knight
here uh you can't take my Pawn on ETA
well I've got another idea I'll go here
and go oh oh wait a minute I can take
this take this take this and then you've
got this other one this queen takes A2
like wait a minute uh so then more or
less where you were going well maybe I
shouldn't put my Bishop on C5 maybe I
should be devoting my Bishop on the the
comfortable Retreat Square D2 when you
go D2 now there's no Knight D1 C3 is
going to force you to recapture and I
could potentially take this Pawn on A2
now if I put the bishop on A3 maybe The
Bishop's less vulnerable than on the C5
square but I really like what you said a
moment ago maybe bishop E7 like wait a
minute uh did uh farouza that's an easy
move to miss right I mean because if the
if you do get to just comfortably
recapture this Pawn then I can start to
believe that whites for choice is there
an opportunity here for diac
with the move Bishop E7 bar
Bishop E7 is definitely playable guys
but I think he already played Bishop A3
but we can look at some of the lines
after Bishop E7 here sure so he will
play the move that you're mentioning in
the different variations he has her C3
here okay you know most likely you can
lose the pawn here but at least you want
to pick up the A2 Pawn Yeah possible so
if you take Queen takes C3 just simply
Queen takes A2 here right and black is
doing great here and the Knight D5 idea
is coming up here as well here okay if
you play Bishop F6 uh there is also this
move 95 here putting pressure on the
queen your knight is also hanging on B2
here right uh Queen takes C6 if we go a
little bit deeper on this line Queen
takes B2 it's pretty clear black is
doing great here this a pawn could be
very dangerous a48382 so that's why this
line doesn't work uh very well here so
after they move C3
you can play the move Knight D1 but the
problem with the bishop p7 now you you
don't get the time to take on F6 here
and now he can play the move 94. and
you're gonna have to probably at some
point move the bishop back to A3 here
and in fact in this position uh black is
already very slightly better here and I
think that's the reason why he played
the move Bishop A3 immediately here and
also Bishop E7 C3 we don't have time to
take on C3 on F6 because of the in
between capture on B2 here so Bishop
Bishop A3 plate and alireza immediately
went through the move C3 which is the
best move here now putting pressure on
the Knight and you have to move the
Knight here again if you take Queen
texture tree after Queen A2 block is
already slightly better here so you have
to play uh you have two options here you
can play Knight D1 or you can play
Knight D3 here as well here so I think
Knight D1 is probably more likely here
just try to finally recapture this Pawn
on C3 Knight E4
trying to make it more difficult because
again if you capture on C3 after the
exchanges the A2 Pawn will be hanging
here right so there is a slow move H3
that you can play but I think it's more
likely we're gonna see the move Knight
C3 played Knight takes C3
Queen takes C3 Queen A2 Rook A1 first
trying to remove the queen but uh Black
is Black is doing uh really well here
actually Rook fc1
you're you're up a pawn here and let's
say Rook C8 again making it difficult to
capture on specific because of that same
idea we looked earlier with Bishop H2
here so I think firusha is doing great
and uh vayak is again I think gonna get
into a time travel he's got about 25
minutes left on a clock I I see some
opportunities here for furuja perhaps to
score his first win
wow uh
slightly better for Ali Reza his first
wit wow uh okay that's still a leave uh
in the game between Richie and Wesley uh
after the move Rook C2 I I was kind of
getting sympathetic to the idea of
Wesley maintaining the Queens on the
board with a move like Queen F5 Wesley
said no no I know that these positions
uh are favorable for for black you just
traded Queens popped his Rook on D5 and
you know it slowly slowly but surely he
will start you know piling up the
pressure against the pawn the backward
Pawn on E2 and white is going to be
forced into a defensive passive possibly
use the king to defend E2 right like I
can imagine you playing for example Rook
C1 or Rook B1 and playing your kingdom
one one of the things that is very very
very strongly advise you not to do this
if you find yourself in these types of
passive positions let me just put this
on the board for just a moment what I
want to say is do not
think oh I'll use my knight as my
defensive resource you will never break
through thanks to this wonderful night
on C1 there is nothing wonderful about
the night on C1 it defends a wonderful
Pawn on E2 but the night on C1 is really
uh gross it can be exactly and
eventually you will just discover that
the the position that night is simply
bitter uh sweet it's just not a good
night so yes I can imagine what you were
saying and I'll say is we bring your
king to F1 use your King as a defensive
piece what about
nepo's position of our in our other key
contest between our tournament
co-leaders who's done what to whom who's
who's made progress yeah let's try to
catch up because they played a lot of
moves since we last look at it the
position is just equal right now and by
looking at it I see that I don't any
problems for Nepal here so but let's
look at the last few moves here so see
how they got here right so we left off
somewhere around here Bishop D4
right here Bishop B6 was played so he
played Bishop D4 Fabiano trying to
exchange this bishop and again after the
move F4 there is always going to be some
problems here some way black can
generate counter play against the weak
E3 Pawn here so Bishop takes D4 plate
Knight takes D4 and now Queen A5 played
uh attacking the pawn on A2 and also
keeping the queen very active here there
are a little bit of dark Square
weaknesses in the White's positions as
you can see A3 B2 C3 squares a little
bit weak and the queen is actually very
well placed in this position here and
another thing to mention here you're
never really afraid of this exchange
here only six if you're wondering what
if you take only six after Fe I think
black will solidify the center and will
actually have perhaps maybe even a
slightly better position here so black
is never really afraid of this move 96
at the moment so Fabiano played Queenie
2 logical move protecting the pawn on A2
and also connecting his Rooks
so Nepal played rookie 8.
H3 uh good move here controlling the
g-force score just in case you want to
put the Rook on D1 you don't want to run
into ideas such as Bishop G4 here and
also with the pawn being weak only three
there could be some options Knight G4 at
some point so H3 is a very useful move
here and Bishop D7 played uh logical
move opening up the file for The Rook to
put pressure on E3 and Rook C8 Rook C8
and now Queen B2 comes in Queen is well
placed here protecting the A2 pawn and
also controlling the C3 Square
at the moment Queen C5 black is trying
to fight for the only open file here and
make it difficult to play the move Rook
C1 very logical play so far I see A4
controlling some squares on a queen side
and
A5 fixing the B4 Square because at some
point now before could be a possibility
for white so A5 played Queen D2
B6 protecting the A5 pawn and a lot of
moves played as you can see here Queen
A3 King H2 and now H6 so it's an equal
position here 38 minutes for Fabiano 51
for uh Nepal Hirsch uh I I think this
game is probably gonna fizzle out to
draw at some point with some kind of
repetition again isolate the pawn on D5
but upon only three is weak and it's
very hard to find any weaknesses in a
Black's position here to generate some
ideas to play for a win yeah that
adjustment of the queen side Pond by
Napo putting the pawns on A5 B6 fixing
the the White Queen side on light
squares I think it was a very good
choice but yeah exactly oh well it is a
day for social media we're getting some
uh tweets thank you very much this one
is from war Daddy
nobody had asked this question before
why do you think Bobby never played
first move E5 with black against Basket
in their world championship match
1972 but instead went for
Aldine and ornithorph or neither well
first of all uh in those days the
Soviets most especially they were very
very they were the world's leaders in
just everything to do with chess most
especially opening Theory and you know
when you think of the hierarchy of the
Chess World Boris basky sitting on top
all of the Soviet theoreticians of Boris
new Theory very very well and if you
looked at the old ecos from those days
the encyclopedias of chess openings it
was like E4 E5 was the thickest Bible
there was and from Bobby's point of view
it was sort of like I'm playing against
the Soviet player but I'm playing
against the Soviet School of Chess why
should I go into the swimming pool
that's deepest and where he has a great
knowledge whereas I Bobby Fischer on the
other hand I I've studied all of these
other variations but most especially I'm
a World's leader in the Sicilian so I
want to play in my part of the swimming
pool and E5 would I think Boris would
have been very very happy I so a good
question but it just helps to know that
you know the Soviets at the time they
were they were they were really really
good in their opening Theory yeah and by
the way unfortunately a World Chess Hall
of Fame just across the street from the
St Louis chess club was just having a
exhibition of the Bobby Fischer match
and just I don't know well you went to
Paris to help
Garner some of the artifacts of that
exhibit exhibition there VAR uh Boris
baskey Jr you had a conversation with
tell us a little bit about that
absolutely it was a lot of fun to meet
Boris Jr and spend five days is with him
and going through this Archives of his
father and you know I learned a lot and
I speak to her I speak Russian so I was
able to translate a lot of this thing
and bring the most important stuff so it
was it was really interesting to get to
know I I feel like I got to know Boris
basket the world champion a lot from
doing this and his uh his communication
with his peers with Bobby Fischer so it
was it was a very interesting experience
for me and I learned a lot by doing this
it was it was really really enjoyable
nice and we have another tweet so let's
see what this this one is from Tobias
yes the question is why do so few grand
Masters play openings like the Vienna or
sketch Gambit most main openings lead to
equality on this level anyway so why not
play lesser known ones
well uh VAR uh you're a chess coach so
why aren't people playing alkynes more
often like Bobby did why are they
more fixated on uh mainstream well I
think some of these openings more rare
openings these days with the modern
engines you're going to be able to
achieve a pretty decent Advantage so
that's the reason you have to stick with
the petrol for Berlin to try to get the
absolute give absolute minimum to White
here it's just analysis and engines are
so much stronger these days and we have
a lot more data so that's why a lot of
this openings that were playable maybe
20 30 years ago these days are you're
just going to be in an inferior position
right out of the opening and struggle
I think it's misleading to assume that a
lot of these openings lead to equal
positions anyways right uh it may come
off as it's oh everybody knows this so
it's going to be equal but it's actually
very hard to achieve that equality with
the black pieces so that's why there are
certain openings that are preferable for
the grand Masters to play where they
know for sure they can get as close to
equality as possible right uh for me I
have a little bit of a different take
myself for example in my career I really
like what we call the modern uh defense
or maybe the perk defense depending and
I like the flexibility of black in the
perk defense the problem when you play
something like the perk defense is that
white has a an enormous array of options
against an early King side fianchetto
and sometimes knowing all of those
different sub lines whether that you
should be playing Bishop E2 or Bishop C4
is white or maybe F3 Bishop E3 Queen D2
and you've got to learn a lot more than
what you probably intended so sometimes
adopting a particular defense and ends
up causing you to analyze so much more
than you then you have to remember all
this like exactly review all the time
right so it's one thing to sit there and
say okay I'm going to learn to play the
the yeah just stop and think about this
I'm going to play the alakine defense
to yourself okay if white wants he can
play the four pawns attack
which is very very very serious or if
white wants he can play Knight F3 and
Bishop C4 and he play can play these
really really slow positions or he could
play these double-edged Gambit positions
with Knight C3 and and C4 C5 and Knight
C3 so suddenly you start thinking
yourself wait a minute I wanted an easy
life I wanted to play something that was
very concrete create and clear and now
I've got three four
main
lines that my opponent can choose from
okay I gotta cut down the option it's
it's getting tough I just wanted to turn
our attention to uh world champion ding
lurin who is struggling against Duda and
when we left it we were looking at this
position to get an advantage correct uh
Knight D5 Knight takes D5 he did spot
that the recapture with the e-pawn was
required this Rook on uh
uh
B6 looks a little forlorn out of the way
but
do that successfully
traded one pair of Rooks you see you
can't head into a completely absolutely
and end game exactly yeah
it really is and this move rookie six
means
a complete trade of everything by the
way that is kind of funny are they
playing checkers yeah somebody tell them
that it looks like it looks like if he
plays G6 now right and uh there's only
one weakness in the position but that is
easily defended on the King on F7 and
I'm sure the players will be looking to
find a a repetition in the position as
this game said for a draw for dingler in
again the newly crowned uh world
champion starting with four draws and
probably a very poor one at that in in
yesterday's outing it's not going to be
happy he's had three out of four games
with white what three games with white
also yes sir three games with white
that's what I mean three out of four
games with white why is ding struggling
in this uh tournament VAR he's not
getting the positions he's known known
for I'm thinking my guess is perhaps
he's just a little bit tired and
overwhelmed after the match and it's
just uh and not getting that many
chances here
especially with the white pieces I mean
he had some chances earlier in this game
at some point he played the move Rook C3
where I I found I moved just slightly
strange here he could have just played
C3 maybe have a little bit of pressure
here
um yeah he's he's not getting anything
uh anything significant we we used to
see him play some sharp lines where he
sacrificed upon some some spectacular
wins complicated positions right now
we're seeing more of some simple play if
I can get maybe some Advantage I can
press otherwise he's okay with the draws
okay well I I see what you mean by the
way that moment where Rook C6 was played
by Duda Rook C3 was simply a helpful
move uh by ding Loren I didn't put
enough pressure on dude as this game is
heading for a draw can we jump to mvl
because that was the scotch uh it still
has that opening a lot of pressure that
he's put in on Anish well the last move
Knight E4 that's kind of a Clarion Bell
I I I'm hearing a bell ringing over here
if you let the Knight
get a sconced and you you can't get rid
of that Knight
on the C5 Square
um
that could be just simply bad news like
really bad news if I have black pieces
King and The Rook looks so limited true
uh The Rook so last few moves let's see
what happened
that MBL did rookie four okay four right
from this um yeah
uh Rover Rook up and over see when he
played H4 early in the opening his goal
was to play Rook h3o K3 which didn't
happen but but he found another way of
getting to the a file that's exactly
right uh okay so in this position
somehow a niche contrived with the idea
that he was afraid that the a pawn might
be weak so he brought his King over to
the queen side to kind of reinforce the
a pawn but now this move Knight E4
by the way let's just go back to the
dingler and game for a moment because we
our producer reckons a handshake is in
the offering do you think Tom's right I
think so absolutely
oh you suck UPS both of you you're
terrible first of all Tom's right and
that's what I thought it was a money
I'm surrounded by Geniuses yeah wow okay
uh dingler and um
okay it's still there's plenty plenty
plenty of tournament ahead I mean
there's no question tournaments like
this you really need to score just one
big win and you can suddenly become a
leader yes we've got four people at plus
one so I think uh to what Vara said
earlier that Ding might be a little bit
tired I would say he must be more tired
than he has ever been in his life I mean
not just physically but emotionally in
every way possible yeah I was surprised
he's even playing in this tournament you
know and not taking a longer break to
process that he just became a world
champion except for one thing it's
called exhilaration nothing gives you as
much energy as a victory I believe you
know you you just played the hardest
thing Phil Cup Tournament of your life
and you should have seen Ali Raisa after
he won uh the sinful Cup last year the
guy had more energy and but he also a
very long break
what we can't see is how tired they feel
yeah okay what's your take uh VAR I um
and I agree I agree yeah lack of energy
definitely with one thing with dingler
and we know he is a strong finisher if
you look go back and look at the
candidate tournament look he started
really poorly and you know he was on a
last place you know really bad start and
then somehow he just at the end he won
several games and just got back into it
winning that last game against Hikaru
and securing the second place which
turned out to be absolutely crucial for
him to play the match against uh against
Nepal so it's possible that you know he
will need one win at some point maybe
you know in a couple of rounds he get
get to that plus one here and try to
fight for the first place here so far we
see it's a very tight field here nobody
is running away with the tournament
nobody has plus three or plus two at the
moment still so I think one win and he
will be back into the race for the first
place okay if I can draw your attention
far to the end game between MBL
Indonesia as we get our
uh yeah we still have one result so far
they can do that
for you to say
the break break down this ending for me
between mvl and Anish for a second
um
I'm two great the problem is the bishop
on D5 is a very good piece I mean it's
anchored in the middle of the board it's
it's looking Queen side it's looking
King side the Knight on C5 is a very
very good piece as well
um I like White's position because of
the structure but is it significant bar
not really it's a very small Advantage
it looks really nice I think optically
yeah optically looks very nice
especially if we get the Rooks off the
board then I think what white will be
extremely happy okay let's say you put a
Pawn on your Rooks are off the board you
bring the king to D4 but I think black
is not gonna exchange the Rooks he's
gonna try to keep his Rook here only
seven try to generate control play with
the ideas like rookie 2 here a very
small Advantage we can we can look at
some of the possible ways how the game
can continue here but evaluation is very
very small uh Edge for white here so for
example after the move rookie seven you
always have to look out for the move
rookie 2 here so and also your G2 Pawn
is hanging here so you need to do uh
something with this so G3 is the best
option here all right so let's say you
start out with that and here actually uh
black has some options here he can play
When the move F6 for example
then you play King D2 trying to improve
the the king and Bishop F3
now trying to get some Contra play with
the move rookie 2 here
if you play Rook F4 trying to remove the
Bishop from there Bishop goes back to
the five here it's very hard to attack
the pawn on A7 I mean you can attack it
once and I have The Rook only seven
already guarding it and this bishop is
doing a great job controlling a lot of
the squares the Knight can go to such as
E6 E4 so it's it's really hard to see
how to make another weakness we know
that we need to create more weaknesses
in this type of end games to have some
real winning chances but the Rook only 7
is also doing a good job controlling the
file and also at the right time getting
to Rook E2 and try to attack the pawn so
very hard to make any progress in this
position he asked for white exactly
which brings up the question that I had
I was about to ask the question when
boink obviously uh mdl played we just
seen the position Bishop D5 I want to
refer you I think it's a move 25. Bishop
D5 and I was wondering about the move
Knight D6 check
the idea is to put the question
immediately to the black king you've got
to make your choice do you go to d8 D7
or B8 if you go to B8 I actually wanted
to chase you all the way into the corner
with Rook before check so let's just
imagine for argument's sake you went to
d8 yeah just throwing that out there
then my idea was to play Knight two
um
provoking to provoking G6 and somehow
this bishop on D5 really is kind of
bothersome I wanted to put the I I I'm
trying to play if you don't mind a kind
of a dark squares right I I want to put
everything I can on the dark swears and
the Knight on E3 gets rid of the bishop
the Knight on C5 looks good but maybe it
doesn't do as much on C5 as it might do
on E3 the current position I agree with
what you're saying the very hard for
white to make inroads on A7 and in the
meanwhile in the current position with
the Rook on E7 always threatening to
come down I feel that the game is a
really balanced I think we're going to
be going to a Bucharest a Christian is
going to have a a guest uh not quite at
this moment
or let's go to Christian and Bucharest
who do you have a Christian with them
I have a very special uh guest the
Yasser I have Gary Kasparov here once
again with me in the studio to look at
the games and share his impressions of
the tournament so far Gary welcome back
to the show um have you been watching
the games today
yeah I've been watching the games not
obviously not much uh to watch but still
you know but they they try obviously
you look at the ding games for instance
he's tired yeah he's tired and he's he's
still probably trying to recover
psychologically from his victory
speaking of that that was the big game
yesterday nepo versus Ding and I think
we discussed it in the middle of the
game Nepal lost some of his Advantage
but still he had some chances he did not
put any pressure yesterday how did you
internalize that result
I think it's it's probably at one point
he just uh
just lost hopes and actually followed
the line that we discussed after rookie
four yeah and he just he recognized the
take on the floor and winning the pawn
and the end game might be
dangerous because black will have a
passport unless he decided that draw is
okay and probably at that time he was
more thinking about where he missed his
chances so that's typically happens you
know you just you play the game but your
mind is yeah yeah you just think oh I
missed this and I missed that I just
yeah I think that was the case yeah yeah
let's discuss uh today's games now for
me at least to my eyes before the games
started this was an interesting one the
one between bogd and Daniel Dak and
alireza because you know both of these
players minus one they don't have
tremendous tournaments up to this point
another with the black piece definitely
wants to put some pressure how uh how do
you feel the opening went on in this but
naturally Bogdan played
because I think his plan was to push
alireza because you know he knew alireza
will try to to do something yeah and and
he just still tried to keep uh you know
position under control but you know it's
it's it's it was not as dull and and and
uninterested as one could have expected
you know after Bishop with your Bishop
D3 actually the idea is just you know
because Paul 96 is a little bit you know
um at this point yeah
because yes H6 is not you know great
great uh um idea for black because it's
for instance yeah
after Bishop D3 if you play immediately
then a black could go Bishop G6 that's
one and and stay there yeah another one
is Pawn on A7 is better better than than
H6 uh another as I tried Bishop before
but preparing E4 because that's clearly
after E4 white has slight Edge so for
example if you go Bishop yeah it's like
and actually A6 here is not no that's
not yes no no no not we're not very
useful I mean in theory now just enough
the exchanges wise rule can appear on D3
Knight on the five Rook on G3 okay in
theory yes but you know it's it's it's
it might be a little bit you know just
it's uncomfortable so otherwise Play
Bishop before he tried to keep pressure
and um and um
yeah now this is interesting moment
because yes this is of the bishop before
1965 this is a trick uh-huh yes oh yeah
here so afterwards
but even after Bishop yes Bishop before
they're still still at the five still
out there yeah yeah five if you do take
still you're not going to go Rook B1 try
to go forward I think I think I did five
I think 95 years yeah
and then just you know just black is yes
yes
so I think that was interesting so
that's why they created some
complications very nice yeah and uh um
B5
but but the the problem is typically you
know this is you can make many active
emotions your pawns but there's one rule
pawns don't go back so that's why you
know when you attack it's like in in in
in in in military uh games and
Battlefield so you you create Witnesses
in your Camp so by by aggressively
pushing he created weakness on C4 it's a
square so ideally you know Black Knight
could appear on on the Square and uh and
it could which almost happened in fact
yeah yeah
I'm sure he had some aggressive
intentions but he had to be very uh
creative because if if Bogdan takes back
the pool
he is his mother structure of course
must be the pawn on C6 is just so he has
to actually lose sipon but creatively
and that's and it was interesting so
this is he tried it right C3 now I
thought about Knight D1
yeah but Knight D1
and then he was 94. yes again this is
this is it's it's he cannot win the pawn
it does right yeah
two years and you don't have time to
take on Seasons yeah yeah it's the
C5
yeah but but again because it won't buy
back in in a comfortable situation yes
because take take E5
so why not Knight C4 I thought this was
his idea yeah but he's still trying to
win I guess yes ah so with a five he's
three days three yeah and now we're five
years yeah yeah but it's this E5 again
that's why
yeah and he played um
E5 directly this is the position
yeah I
found it can you play Queen C2 here okay
let's take this
and now E4 okay to play it like this
yeah
say I go here and now you just stop me
with F1 yeah
and I will go Knight D3 and you know
it's a nice spot sacrifice yeah does any
of this can make but maybe we should be
six yes
yeah the thing is the Knight on B6
doesn't have where to go yeah but still
um
yeah
I don't want to take takes C5
it's an interesting position
yeah it's again the systems that this
position is it looks very simple but
many but this is the problem or the time
17 minutes for that move 23rd exactly
that's that's that's a problem that's a
lot timing time time time time time time
oh by the way you know this is the what
about playing E4 immediately oh okay
I'll take this
week
and just play like this I will take that
one back yeah yeah
good night A4 probably is Knight A4
Rotex is six and then just defend like
this and then the bishop goes on I guess
that Knight on C3 is gonna be pretty
good yeah
yeah like this
yeah
still thinking all right uh by the way I
do think that Fabiano I'm not 100 sure
if they have repeated already but they
were going to repeat maybe we can get uh
panoramic of the playing hole and maybe
we can see whether yeah
this is the game that this is the
opening yes the city Forest that's what
chronic plays yeah yeah in 1996 I lost
the game actually this is because it was
I was a novelty but just I was a bit
surprised it was a blitz lie break and I
lost the game so and I didn't manage to
win the game too so this was a final of
Moscow rabbit in 96. and how did uh I
play Bishop with two but purple but
that's exactly what I did now the
freebies A6 I I think I came back I came
back but black has a very comfortable
position very comfortable
so he played Bishop D3 and Knight E5 and
by the way nepo was blitzing out his
moves maybe some residual preparation
from approaches
easy easy drawing yeah
I almost felt like at some point he was
trying a little bit on Apple
probably not
and this is what we have right now lots
of exchanges nothing has changed the
position repeat it once probably they
will repeat twice this is a pretty dry
um which one thing we ran we've
discussed that now yeah that was
interesting so that's the envious H4
yeah
what's your experience with this not
with H4 was this position a lot of
experience yes what was H4 yeah you've
never played H4
I will see for us but H4 is yeah it's
that's you got some some sliders
invited the same game and then this is
what we have right now Bishop G5 make
use of that age hormone at least
and we are in this position right now
how would you assess it
any chances for white
maybe King D2 try to invite rookie 2 and
King D3 or King C3
I don't think you can take right
they take for King D3 first
I mean this is with the a pawn running
and I don't see fire pretty strong
against yeah maybe
maybe I can find the construction yeah
the bishop is good yeah
the question is whether it's enough or
serious advantage or not
so Rooker four
so I cannot start giving you checks and
pick up the pawn because I'm losing
peace
maybe you can do
okay yes so here here
foreign
yes
still some pressure it feels like
yeah so I think he oh sorry this is
he has to go away because otherwise
the
drop the bishop back but you just got
there you just played Bishop 3.
some pressure for for white yes
what about timing
34 minutes for MPL 26 minutes doesn't
seem like they're heavy towards any sort
of time but it's almost unpleasant I
think this is you you're worse it's
probably a draw yeah but you don't know
how to make a voice yeah you have to
fight and now he has to decide whether
he goes for this just for this exchange
I think it's probably typically Bishop
versus knight you know you have to open
the position here so yes making this
balance uh by the way uh we're being
told that Richie versus Wesley are
repeating right now let's see where the
repetition is equal to H5 King G2 rookie
five
um are we seeing a handshake right now
or is the big question can Richie try
for more with H4 H4 you go G5 right is
so now you cannot
take
yeah Richard is still trying to find
something I don't think he's going to
but playing rusi too but that doesn't
make much sense yes
you can play by this but
but so what's next yeah what's next so
Knights cannot go from B3 to C4 by Magic
yes
violation of the rules yes you would
love together yeah yeah yeah no so can I
do Rook E1 and then Rook C2 light no but
that doesn't work either
seems like they're stuck in in this
position
repetition is incoming
um and the final game I actually think
we've seen most of the games
it's okay the
alireza it's probably the most
interesting one so that's uh that's the
that's that's the one oh some stuff has
happened 34 immediately yes it did and
queen d8 not Queen takes this queen D4 I
thought maybe maybe he wouldn't play
quick no maybe Queen C2
now he has to go back on T8 already a
queen gets trapped you have to go back
on d8 and then maybe I don't know 51
Rook D1 or Knight yes or maybe 93 first
. I like it yes
there's some pressure yeah that Bishop
on C7 if you don't find a good spot for
it soon yeah and where is the good spot
on F6 I mean that's not really yeah so
E4 yeah yeah I like this yes
we have this on the board right now
nice Advantage for bogdon
not a lot of risk right yeah this is no
that's no risk no risk at all yeah yeah
no risk at all because Black Knight on
B6 is
um yeah it's not uh it's not ideal
located
yes yeah yeah yeah
interesting position definitely this one
developing nicely
um still long time but he's accustomed
to it that's his usual playing style
Gary thank you very much for joining
what are your plans for the your living
Bucharest tonight is that correct or
tomorrow morning or early morning so
that's the
go back to New York I have a few events
there in New York and then fly back to
Europe you're excited about having
Magnus in Poland in a couple of weeks so
to see mag was back at chess board
though it's not classical chess but yeah
still entertaining so I know
a few of you guys soon also yes
absolutely Gary thank you very much for
joining us
and we will be going on a short
commercial break be before we return
with the rest of the games
[Music]
it's 2023 and the grand chess tour is
back for its eighth trip around the
world inspired by former world champion
Gary Kasparov the grantchester hosts the
top players to compete for top prizes
eight of the world's best joint
tournament wild cards and travel to four
different countries to fight for a 1.4
million dollar prize fund the tour kicks
off in Bucharest Romania for the
Superbad chess classic then things speed
up as we move to Warsaw Poland and
Zagreb Croatia for the first two rapid
and Blitz events the tour then makes its
way to St Louis Missouri for the final
two events we're back in November for
the St Louis rapid and Blitz and the
illustrious sinkfield cup when points
are up for grabs the best players show
up who will be crowned the new Champion
find out when the grand chess tour
returns
meet me at the beauty the beauty in
Forest Park the muni's premier season
bursting with comedy's romance and Magic
Begins June 12th with the muni premiere
of beautiful the Carole King musical
the Epic summer continues with Disney's
Beauty and the Beast chess West Side
Story Little Shop of Horrors rent and
Sister Act
single tickets are now on sale at
muni.org
Forest Park
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
chess classic and these are the results
so far right so far we only have one
draw between Ding and Duda we expect
more will be coming shortly but that's
where we stand at the moment what are
the most confounding decisions I've seen
in a long time between Richard Rapport
and Wesley so two of our co-leaders uh
clashing in this all-important game and
I had been installing the virtues of
this position for uh Wesley for some
Time Expo explaining why and how this
Pawn on D4 this black Pawn on D4 really
cramps whites structure that white is
perpetually tied to this Pawn on E2 and
then out of the blue Wesley decides to
give up this powerful d E4 Pawn for
lousy H2 part and there the players are
now in a four Rook ending where I think
nobody has an advantage
but I don't even think why it's worse at
all anymore no not at all after this
movie yeah I mean it's right why does
Richard that is to say is ready to play
Rook C4 and keep making a few more
mistakes and maybe I start getting
interested for white suddenly so that
was a very strange decision to to to
voluntarily trade the pawn on D4 for the
pawn on H2 and Richard is uh doing fine
going to our other two co-leaders and
that of course is between Fabi and
um nepo
um one of the great myths
in chess is this idea that Queen and
Knight usually outplay Queen and Bishop
well for those of you have ever read
John Watson's modern chess
work on Modern chess he just puts paid
to that idea and queens and Bishops
actually do work well with one another
however this is one of those positions
where
I might make an argument that the Knight
on D4 is doing a little bit more I have
a few more options I don't think it's
anything at all per se but okay maybe
maybe Fabi is uh has to be preferred by
a smidge what's your take uh let's
exchange the Queens then I would prefer
White
oh you think the Queen's off yes would
enhance and why would why do you think
that just a simple good night versus bad
Bishop because of the part on e4 just
because of the Pawn on e4 which is over
pushed maybe where a white if white were
to rearrange pieces and put the King on
D4 in the end game okay that would be a
problem for a black so then I can put it
to you very succinctly in this position
move ago Fabi played the move Queen E2
and that would not have been your move
your move might have been Queen C2 right
inviting the trade of queens and this is
this is what you were saying that you
would aspire to to play if you were in
Fabby shoes so he did play the move
Queen E2
you see thinking
uh yeah kind of crawl his way into the
A6 Square far jumped in is this a
position where the chess engines are
enamored by the night or
no it's as expected yesterday zero zero
zero yeah
and then if well is Nazi right should
she should Fabi have played her move
Queen C2 let's take a look uh if we see
two plate in this position so if you
play Queen C2 here try to trade Queens I
think what's gonna happen is this
blocking is gonna try to get to C5
pretty quickly here so Queen takes C2
right Knight takes C2 now
King E7 right let's say you bring the
Knight back to D4 because if you play 96
there is some Knight F5 ideas but Bishop
D7 okay just um it's actually this
concept is very important you know the
the Knight is on D4 you want to keep the
bishop on D7 to control the squares F5
B5 so it's kind of you're restricting
the Knight on D4 by putting the bishop
on D7 so if you try to because my king
is coming to before you need to bring
the king to C3 actually King E2 King D6
King C5 and now King C3 and now in this
position you might you may try to play
the move G4 here to expand Libby so
that's why this move H5 is I think quite
important here to try to prevent that
from happening and here white doesn't
really have any options here because
with this pawns being fixed like this A3
before you can never really play the
move before because you're always going
to have problems with the A4 Pawn
hanging so computer is suggesting just
to play H4 and just try to shut down the
game like this with G3 and uh so it just
never makes it to D4 yeah right yeah if
you trade Queens I think there's just no
winning chances perhaps Fabiano is
trying to keep the Queens on the board
to see if he can try to create some
chances there
um let's let's see here on the current
position with the current position Queen
C3 played actually by nepo it's a very
good move here trying to activate if you
move the queen now you always have to
worry about the move uh Queen D2 check
yes so Queen D1 is one of the best moves
but now I think black has many options
here can play the move Bishop D7 once
again to get that same concept of
restricting
uh the Knight on D4 uh of course with
Knight F5 played you have to be careful
this is not a blunder you're not
blundering the Knight there's a
background Checkmate here on d8 so yeah
you have to watch out for that but
against Knight F5 you can play the move
Queen C6 for example just to defend and
now you have to move the Knight probably
back to D4 uh if you put it on D6 it's
not really attacking anything there so
so for so after Knight F5 there there
are some options here to play F5 but I
think block position in general is very
very solid here so I expect this game to
end in a draw at some point Thank you
for it's not like the the excitement is
overwhelming and boiling and something
like that but I will point out that in
the game between dioc and Ali Reza
a double-edged positions on the board I
like White's position I hate diox clock
times he's got 13 uh moves to make and
he's uh always been the one who's
perpetually in time trouble all of his
games up to this point I mean shockingly
enough uh he's two out of three draws he
did lose the one game but if you look at
the positions he could easily be 0-3 uh
if we could bring up the game and just
take a look at his clock for a moment
and again
on the white side against Ali Reza six
minutes six minutes for for for the time
yeah
but things have changed a lot since we
last looked at this position he did and
somehow it became very favorable for uh
for uh dayak when we saw the position we
had seen him more or less with the move
C3 and we thought okay uh this is fine
maybe even more than five right like he
could be better and after 93 94 Knight
C5
92 uh okay that's
strange move and
it was this move E4 that really kind of
turned the tables in White's favor Queen
d8 Rook D1 and we're catching up quickly
to the players Rook F1
well really would you have played Rook
F1 there this idea G3 and F4
yeah I guess he was afraid of allowing a
trade of uh also maybe black was thrown
in Rook d8 yeah not threatening but but
okay looked the queen A1 I have to
defend and put the other Rook on d8
maybe okay
but it's kind of strange because there
was this Rook on D1 and he kind of
voluntarily I'm not one of those who who
gives up the open file easily you know
with my Rook uh Rook F1 right here uh
VAR Jump Right In would be would Rook F1
been your Top Choice ruke fauna is
actually one of the top moves here
okay but I want to go back a little bit
Yeah so to point out where alireza made
the mistake because we actually liked
his position and I even mentioned that I
think he has some chances here to try to
play for a win but there is one
particular move he made that actually
turned things around here and he's
slightly worse right now so right in
this position here 92 is actually fine
this idea to try to trade but the
logical continuation after this would be
to bring your knight into the game with
the temple now attacking the queen and
even though Bishop might seem a little
bit passive but it's still it's it's
it's important to to capture this bishop
here so Queen D3 or queen C3 force and
now you take and queen take perhaps here
he thought you know he has this a
backward panel C6 here but it's still
not so easy for white to untangle here
so you play the move Bishop D6 now
you're pinning this Knight and now
you're threatening Rook B five ideas and
you cannot easily move the queen from A3
because you have the A2 Pawn hanging so
still black is the one a white is the
only one who needs to find some accurate
moves here so the best way to equalize
is to play Queen A4 right now Rook to B4
comes in with the tempo perhaps Queen C2
now and here you have options you can
play Rook a b but simplest is simply to
take on C5
Queen takes C5
and now you can even play
Rook A4
putting pressure on A2 and queen takes
C6
you can play Rook A2 here as well
and this apoc would be very dangerous
here and I think with accurate play
White should be okay here but uh black
is the only one who has chances like if
you try to exchange the queens now and
try to go after that pawn that line is
very dangerous because the a pawn is
going to be very very quick with a483
and uh speaking of the current position
for a moment with the inclusion of the
move Rook F1
white has an upper hand but it's about
the clock
right how big is White's deox Advantage
Daniel's Advantage uh at this moment and
it's not very big it's just a very small
advantage and a very small Advantage
here uh this E4 move on move 24 where he
played this was a critical move I think
perhaps maybe alireza missed this move
E4 because he if he takes on D4 after
the recapture here then you have to move
rook fd1 and position is more
simplifying and white is slightly better
here and if you play a move like a
bishop E5 then this 93 is just going to
be excellent here putting pressure on
the bishop and now you can pick up the
pawn on C6 with a very nice Advantage so
I think perhaps he might have missed
this move E4 and now the current
position after the move Queen C3 here
black still has some ideas here Queen H5
in particular is the best move here very
concrete putting pressure now on uh H3
you can play the move G3 and then Bishop
will go to E5 it's it's it's it's hard
to come consolidate the position if
white can manage to that maybe he will
have some chances but I think it's a
dynamic equality and with the clock
situation I think there are still
chances here uh for for fioruja 10 more
moves to go yeah sir six minutes for
Jack all right thank you for that uh VAR
I'm just looking at uh Fabi versus Yan
again it's queen of Bishop versus queen
and Knight and there's some chewing and
throwing they're excited for a second
when I saw the queen on A6 right that's
what he played the queen D2 check uh
forced the knight uh to drop back
uh check Force the bishop to drop back
and somehow the queen so back and forth
but all right from uh Bobby's point of
view if it was his turn he played the
move Knight D4 and the E4 Pawn could be
a concern and our other game it seems to
me that Wesley and Richard are racing
towards a draw again this was the four
Rook ending and I don't know I think
that players after for example Rook A5
we could see lots of Trades and three
versus three yes I think mvl is still
trying to find a way to put more
pressure on Anish all right yes this was
again uh the position hasn't changed
that much I think they moved half all
the pieces but it's it's still about the
same position the professional wood
shuffling going on here Knight C5 check
I'm just looking at I don't see any uh I
always look for those I can't my
opponent uh walk into a Checkmate maybe
he can King B6 yes exactly if King B6
and if you're if you're not paying
attention if you don't
cover the A6 Square for a moment
you I can make you walk the plank
mate yeah yes so uh I don't like B4 and
black in The Rook on A4 either no
because if black doesn't miss the maid
yeah
doesn't work right right yeah uh your
opponent walking in into a mate
um I mean it's it's still early days but
somehow uh exciting games kind of turned
into a little bit of a yawner we might
be seeing more draws today than we used
to we're kind of getting spoiled I think
so we're going to see some draws here
for sure not much is happening in this
game here in particular but I think in
one game I think Jan made some
inaccuracies and now I think Fabi has
some some Advantage here I want to maybe
switch to that game sure so
so here actually it's already we see a
little bit of an advantage here for
white 0.6 and we see now the bishop is
very passive on E8 right so let's go
back
to this position here so he played uh
Queen C3 Queen A6 and he he also had the
option of playing Queen B2 check this
was another alternative here
the idea is you if you go back 92 here
the B3 Pawn is hanging that is the
difference between uh the move Queen D2
check here so here actually after Queen
B2 check computer shows King F1 Queen C1
and a drop but let's let's go to the
westless game because I think we might
see a draw in that game yeah very very
shortly as the players have transposed
to The Rook M3 versus rook and three
they'll be uh looking uh to after a move
light G6 figuring out
oh excuse me H4 uh
an extra Pawn trade uh figuring out the
fastest way to a three move
repetition
handshake coming up
in this game this is the only time the
situations like this where I don't like
the no draw for rule right yeah here you
sort of but you know I'd much rather
you know suffer through the players uh
doing it uh what they're doing now than
the alternative I agree which is I I
really love those positions that they're
super sharp you know somebody's made
some sacrifice to create an attack and
then the player suddenly agreed to a
draw because one of them is in time
trouble yeah and everybody's scared yeah
and the audience is so dissatisfied you
made this great attack and you made a
draw offer why did you make the draw for
oh my clock was short two draws uh
there's that game is official uh back to
you you were just saying uh VAR that
lepo
made some error yeah I think an apple
misplayed it here in the current
position I see some chances here for
Fabiano in particular the bishop is
quite passive on E8 and it's going to
take some time to bring this bishop into
the game let's take a look what are the
some of the options in this position for
for Nepal try to defend here so it's
already showing that he needs to play a
move like H5 which is not easy to find
here because you don't really want to
push the Pawns in this position uh that
early there is there is a defensive move
Queen E7 but again not a very natural
move the queen is kind of active here
and you're bringing it back to the
defense here now I think white wants uh
to put the Knight on D4 and then you can
have problems with the E4 Pawn here
exactly so somehow I think Fabi uh
tricked Yan in this position and again I
think this move Queen D2 it looks very
natural but Queen B2 was much more
precise here to make sure this B3 Pawn
is hanging right and after Queen B2 uh
one of the main moves here it's just we
could see the game actually ending like
this into a repetition here we already
analyzed the move Queen E2 here because
the Queens will come off the board and
Bishop D7 that that is just the equality
but so what happened now after Queen D2
check uh Fabi played Knight E2 and now
we we see a problem here B6 Pawn is
hanging so he had to go back now a queen
before and now Queen C8 check the bishop
is hanging now forcing the bishop back
to E8 and now Queen C2 very good move
here perhaps this is the move maybe
Nepal means he was maybe thinking 94 he
has Queen D2 and they will repeat here
but after Queen C2 now white is
consolidating the position and now
threatening to put the Knight on D4 and
you need to protect this E4 Pawn so it's
not so easy now again you need to find
some H5 mode for example again this is
counter-intuitive now Knight D4 now
perhaps you have to play H4 give up the
pawn on e4 and look for some Contra play
with the move Queen D2 here
counter intuitive indeed and let me just
uh throw the ball to Bucharest Christian
with a special guest
we are here with Andre diakonescu
co-founder of one United properties one
of our big sponsors here at Super bet
just classic Andre welcome to the show
uh tell us a bit about yourself as well
as this partnership between one United
properties and super batches classic
well thanks for the invitation
um we love to be part of this uh of this
event
we love to be part of the
phenomena of Chess in general
as myself I've been passionate about
Chess from a very young age
unfortunately I didn't go
um
deep into it because I had other
priorities but now that you know we
establish the business and we've grown
and so on I if I've found enough time to
allocate
both playing and
um
providing by way of sponsorship
towards the sport you're also the vice
president of the Romanian Chess
Federation and you're talking about the
Young Generation how important it is for
the Young Generation to have these Role
Models come here in Bucharest like
dingley ran the world champion
players of this caliber well I think
I think an event like that and and the
presence of such important players uh
will give a big boost uh to uh an entire
Young Generation who is passionate about
Chess so I think uh that uh the fact
that we we are we are being involved in
this and we uh we have managed to
organize uh such uh an event at such a
level
um will will for sure
um feed our our Young Generation for the
next perhaps five to ten years and will
for sure uh see results in that period
and we see already results we have
Bogdan Daniel that here we have Richie
report when do you think we're going to
see the next big super Talent come from
Romanian chess I think I think uh I hope
I actually that the next important is
already born it's just we haven't seen
him yet obviously this player that you
mentioned are extremely good yeah they
play at the top level but I truly hope
that the effort that we are doing now
especially with the chess in schools and
so on with more than 20 000 uh
players that are certified uh will will
bring the big mass and will will have
enough risk will provide enough enough
resource for many top level players in
the years to come I'm feeling the
Strategic thinking behind all this plan
uh great thank you very much for joining
us thank you for all the support and
we'll let you go enjoy the games now
thank you very much as well thank you
Christian and indeed at all of the
support that is going on in Bucharest is
really uh laying a very fertile
ground for the rise of
a future Champion whoever they may be
yeah yeah
um looking at the game of uh a niche I
feel that mvl that game seems to be
heading to a draw the the action is and
sorry to interrupt you yeah I think
white actually has some idea while oh
please while we're listening I was
thinking about this what if I go back
Rook A5 and I want to give Knight A4
check okay so Rook A5 I'll play along go
ahead all right my day for check I've
got to uh keep the pawn now I bring the
Rook to the king side uh F5 let's go to
F5 F5 all right
so essentially you're saying you want
your night back yes but you Rook on A4
is kind of like okay I'm free you're
freeing The Rook uh fair enough and
um I'll I'll play like go ahead uh how
can you play G6
that would be too compliant yeah okay I
won't be I won't go that far but all
right and and here I wasn't sure if
white should include A4 A5 or okay
or wait for a bit and maybe improve the
king's position King
D4 I don't know where I'm going though
yeah well that was the question I always
thought that The Rook on E7 was a
counter play in this particular case I I
probably want to release my Rook so I'll
play a move like F6 just so that I could
go to the seventh right or second rank
Part B in this case without allowing
Rook F7 still a lot of work ahead I I
understand what you're saying I'm
sympathetic to the idea that uh The Rook
really on A4 isn't that good F5 makes a
better impression the question is will
it be enough
uh really I think the action of VAR is
in the dioc game uh Ali Reza uh being uh
the once who's maybe in the worst
position that has his opponent in
serious time trouble
absolutely yes sir and that's why he
played the move uh Knight C8 he's trying
to keep the pieces on the board in
particular there was a line if he had
played through kb8 it would have allowed
white to repeat the position with Knight
A6 rupee 7 Knight C5 for example so
there is playing for the win the act
just made a move with I think three
seconds on a clock
yeah yeah I think he has now 33 seconds
after completing that move so so let's
take a look uh at the current position
he played Bishop C1 looks like right
you want
okay so Bishop to C1 came Bishop C1 and
now um Rook B8 would be a logical move
to finally bring this piece into the
game yeah putting pressure on the queen
there there on move number 32 so still
eight more moves to go for deak
basically he has to play this most on
the increment and now the queen is under
attack so you need to find a good Square
for the coin it's not easy to see where
this queen should go because if you go
to E3 then it's you're gonna run into
Bishop D4 idea it's still okay but you
have to go Queen A3 so I don't think
we're going to see the move Queen E3
played okay another option is Queen C
Queen C4 but in this case now we see the
Knight jumping in on B6 with the tempo
and you can play Queen E2 but this seems
like uh yeah you don't you don't have
any advantage now and I think block is
gonna try to create
some chances perhaps right at least
until the time control is completed
sorry for I was thinking Black Knight
could come to B5 and D4
so Knight B5 yeah this is an also
possibility
do you like including Rook B8 Mercy or
do you want to play Knight D6
right here 96 right here okay ah let's
go back to that then
um so 96 immediately with
ideas of Knight B5 to D4 it's strange
this bishop on A3
I assume he brought it back because he
wants to put his Bishop on E3 would you
continue with the Knight B5 yeah that
makes sense because you can play Queen
seforno I have a fork
through that through that Queen C4
Knight A3 uh would uh force me uh
to offer a trade in Queens
um
it's strange I mean there's this weak
Pawn on C6 but this Knight on C5 is is
blocking my view absolutely yeah it's
very hard to get to that C6 Pawn it's
really uh Rook B8 just played by the way
the queen is under attack eight
and now Queen A4 by dayak and did he do
that with with time on his clock
Queen A4 looks like a bad move after
Rook P5 yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa Rook B5 yes I
could get my queen trap can I would be
five and Rook D4 is the idea yeah
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa or even
like it might have been a blunder uh-oh
uh oh even night like for example let's
say I play a week blue and I I could
easily
be you know uh set up for uh
bad bad things Queen A4 I don't know VAR
my spidey sense is tingling uh deox may
be in trouble big trouble action a queen
A4 is a blunder and if alireza finds the
move Rook B5 I think he has a very easy
plan after Knight B6 is coming up if
Queen doesn't have any scores to go to
if you go to A3 you always gonna run
into the bishop D6 idea and with the
time situation I think if he plays Rook
B5 you will have excellent chances to
win this game and again a lot of
complications and diac didn't navigate
through it correctly and because of the
time situation and uh Rook B5 is a very
logical move instead of move uh Queen A4
he had to play as we were looking at
possibilities of a queen C4 probably the
best way to play that's what I would
probably try to do in this position
Knight D6 and queen E2 just try to
liquidate the queens of the board and
perhaps you you know endgame should be
about equal in this position so now
after Queen A4
yeah Rook B5 and it should be uh very
very all right I have a question after
Queen A4 of course Rook B5 looks great
but can black also play Rook D1 instead
D1 let's see here Rook D1 actually in
this case now they just take on D1 queen
queen takes D1 and just King G2 and Rook
B1
this is not winning
let's see here
it looks scary to me I mean we're in
this very unpleasant and um okay there
is a queen takes C6 looks like just
escaping on time with this queen C8
Queen F5 idea oh my
um
[Music]
oops what
foreign
I was about to say I thought I had a
Perpetual at least the moment you play
Queen E5 to defend the bishop right I
would I would have to do that just
Bishop E3 Yasser after Bishop G7 just
play Bishop B3 you already have two
pawns and uh actually a very strong
compensation here I see in 96 yeah and
96 is not running away okay we have some
oh we have a lot of moves let me just
refresh
we have Rook the one on the board and
well when you see the move Rook D1
you're really attracted to it I mean
right I mean the moment you started
talking about it with Rook B1 you go wow
okay Rook D1 on the board not Rook beef
hard
so if white if there found the queen C6
idea I guess it was equal yes but he has
no time so yeah but Rook D2 uh was on
the board so H2 is hanging but d8
um
shall we have a look yes let's take the
pawn
let's just have a look and to see
what's going on we're allowing a rook d8
check and
um I'm not worried because I'm not
paying my Rook is protected right yeah
and you you always have this kind of uh
Rook to be one ideas and here we go Ali
Reza is is asking the same questions
dioc is so happy that he could play King
takes F1 and gained 30 seconds on his
clock uh coach
what do you tell
uh your students who are time trouble
addicts as seems to be Daniel's problem
in this tournament
yeah it's a really difficult problem to
fix Yasser because it's uh it will take
a lot of time and luckily I don't have
too many students right now that have
this problem are suffering yeah yeah
absolutely because it's uh it's it's
it's not easy it just one thing I would
suggest you need to be more practical be
aware of of your time situation and one
of the recommendations I have is just
trying not to spend more than 15 minutes
because if you already spend that much
time you already know what the move you
should play and you should just go for
it basically trust your instincts if you
spend more time it's just here more
thinking it's just gonna you know you're
gonna hesitate more and more likely to
make a mistake for example knowing
myself that's when I make a lot of
mistakes when I spend more time and I
don't trust my intuition exactly it
shows a lot a lack of self-confidence in
the fact that you're you keep analyzing
the same things by the way
instead of allowing a rook to Rook to d8
uh Queen takes H2 Rook to d8 check
faroogian thought he was being clever by
including the move Knight V6 and I have
a little questions about that because
again that Rook on V8 is being blocked
and we like the idea of Rook B1 I like
your idea for Beyond one uh very much
Queen D1 here and still have Rook d8
ideas now with a better version because
Knight on B6 would be hanging oh oh I
was lucky for farrugia that that the uh
the The Rook on B8 is the
defended in Queen D1 looks right Queen
takes H2 a light your check and if I was
forced to play Rook takes d8 I'd be
crying but King H7
but I think uh di takes c61.
Queen D1 looked logical and we were just
looking at that Queen takes C6 again uh
dioc playing with uh literally
increments
um
whoa uh isn't he playing with fire after
Queen takes H2 I mean there's a bishop
hey four is coming
four Rook B one and
uh black is one having a lot of fun
suddenly Queen takes H2 hold on do we
have immediately nights before I was
about to ask
can't why do I need Queen to H2 anymore
I mean if I could play Rook B1 right
here right now I'd be golden so Knight
C4 immediately
uh my spidey sense is tingling here I'm
sensing opportunity VAR is there
opportunity after Knight C4 Queen H2
Knight C4 still is better Yasser but
white has the smooth Rook D5 okay yeah
instead instead of the Knight C4 Rook
seat is actually winning uh I can show
that line but let's take a look at the
Knight C4 how is white holding here
after uh that so if Knight C4 yes Rook
D5 it looks looks very very scary robot
B1 Rook B1
there's Knight D3 crazy damn it now
Queen C8 Queen C8 check or actually 93
here immediately yeah you're you're
defending to check it's just incredible
you have to play can you one loses to
Knight F3 so you have to play King G2
and then allow this queen F3 and here
actually plaque doesn't have anything
better than just to give a Perpetual no
uh triple zeros you know that's crazy
you you just you march the king up the
board and you can't uh no Checkmate no
checkmates crazy okay so sorry Queen
takes C6 is a mistake mistake Queen
takes H2 is just winning now because
threatening to check on H1 and pick up
the bishop he's much he's munched on H2
as you're about to suggest yes 97 is the
best move then you have Rook B8
attacking the queen queen has to take on
B6 then we have Rook take C1 check King
goes to E2 and now very important check
here Queen H5
and now you're forced to play F3 sorry
let me just catch okay first of all uh
apologies uh to interrupt you there VAR
uh he didn't play the Knight D7 move
that you suggested we do have Queen
takes C6 Queen H2 on the board Knight D3
please pick it up from this moment after
Knight D3 yeah after Knight D3 here's
just a queen H1 check yep
yep and now very strong move here is
Bishop D4 quiet killer quiet uh but it's
got a very nice idea behind it you first
protect your knight on B6 I love it
putting pressure on F2 and actually the
most important threat now is Rook C8
exactly pressure on the queen and try to
move the queen from this diagonals to
pick up the E4 pawn and here's the best
line actually is to play Rook C2 okay
and just to sacrifice own C8 here after
the move Rook C8 Queen takes C8 Knight
takes C8 Rook CA check King H7 but this
is just a completely losing position you
have uh rook and a knight but your E4
Pawn is still hanging your king is weak
and black is just winning here and we do
have Queen H1 check King E2 on the board
now it's the time for The Quiet killer
Bishop D4 and things have suddenly
perked up big time
uh mvl Anish Gary draw that's not an
expected but in a marquee matchup of our
tournament co-leaders uh holy smokes is
Fabi
wow what a move F7 F5 it's hard for me
to imagine that that that nepo
voluntarily played that move black has
weakened the king side so much what if
white just terrible Queen C7 right now I
mean Wild Horses could not stop me from
playing Queen C7 right now that is
looking
uh um excuse me uh uh alert alert
Will Robertson danger and I think
neposition's second time trouble because
they have passed the time control
they're on move 45 okay it's down to 10
minutes
in this very uncomfortable position nepo
who is there yeah wow uh for a player
who is perpetually ahead of his
opponents this is a
is very unusual to see nepo uh the ones
suffering on the clock uh well we'll
keep an eye on this one they have still
lots of time let's go back to the dioc
Ali Ali razor game and we do have I
believe Bishop D4 on the board that
quiet killer Rook d2d1 Tempo against the
queen uh VAR had been pointing out that
Rook C8 was on uh the agenda ooh I think
black's about to win Queen H5
and the only winning move wow
wow but that's nasty King E1 on the
board
Rook C8 right
Rook C8
now the problem is if I just move my
queen I'm allowing this why the king
looks uncastled even though it was
castled before right
maybe your best move is to Castle and
put the Rook on F1 uh this looks
terrible this looks terrible uh
just uh
a lot of time
I mean I know yeah I know the the arc is
relying upon is they just made a 40th
move already they did make the 40th move
okay but after Rook C8 I think the
engine eval is going to be huge am I
guessing correctly
uh voice yes it's like a plus plus seven
right now actually seven yeah plus seven
in fact uh uh maybe he hasn't played it
yet Rook C8 but uh in just in case he
asked that if he wants he can repeat one
more time with Queen H1 and then then
play the move Rook C but I think Rook C8
is very natural move and uh it's just
the game is over after this well exactly
that once you see this move Bishop on E5
to D4 protecting the Knight and
unleashing the Rook with a gain of tempo
uh one of the things
yeah I I really felt that I was becoming
a chess master when I began to really
understand the idea of winning Tempe
attacking my piece and my opponent's
pieces and and gaining uh development
for myself so as I became strong and
stronger I was always looking out for
those game those moves that would win me
10p so to to my way of thinking Rook C8
was embedded suddenly I was hardwired to
finding moves like Queen H1 check checks
I always looked at first because those
were the most forcing and then the
secondly those attacking moves that gain
time so Rook C8 would be like you know
ingrained in my mind and I would be
looking at that we do have Rook C8 Queen
D7 and is it that Rook C2 move or is
there something even more the size of
the Rook C2 at this moment Queen F3 is
the key move here Queen F3 Rook sir two
I think white has Knight F4 with the
tempo
no I don't think so there's Bishop F2
never mind
let me yeah it says fighting what you
may have missed yeah good morning St
Louis right uh uh Queen F3 oh that looks
really nice
I mean that just you know then why
wasn't rooksetto winning immediately
that is a good question why was it Rook
C2 a video
is also really good but there's a rook
D2 defense there uh Rook D2 defense just
it's temporary but Queen F3 is like one
of those moves that just asked the ask
your opponent find the move you're you
can't live your knight this this
fellow's hanging
um you can't play Bishops everyone is
bad your queen is somehow
stuck in Rook D2 every move drops
something else exactly exactly it looks
it looks like Queen F3 is almost a a
kind of a zoo
now maybe we can just take a pause and
take a look at the other uh remaining
game we have three out of five three out
of the five games of the round have been
drawn but in a matchup of the co-leaders
we think Fabio has a great chance right
here right now after F7 F5 Queen C7
tickling the bishop and uh
how is nepo supposed to resist
uh I think nepo is in very very big
trouble yaser just that it's that simple
it's really bad if Bobby plays Queen z7
he has excellent winning chances big
Advantage I wanted to go back a little
bit and maybe analyze this position here
and just get your opinion guys so like
for example if I'm here blocking this
position I would be a little bit
hesitant to play the move Knight E4
because that changes the structure and
frees up the you know position for the
Knight to be on D4 so uh I I might
consider like maybe playing a queen
system just try to sit on the position
for a second here because the last move
was Knight C2
and I'm not sure exactly what is white
trying to do because you don't really
want to play before a four pound will be
hanging so 94 is still okay but it just
changes the character of the position so
for example I think Queen C7 would have
been a good choice as well just to ask a
question what are you going to do next
right because you don't really have uh
too many ideas and again computer
analysis to go back here and then you go
back to C5 for example this is maybe a
way that Nepal could have just played
and made an easy draw here but instead
he played Knight E4 and now this leads
to a completely different type of
position now Bishop takes E4 and at
least and now Knight is well placed here
and again in this position I'm not sure
if I want to move this Bishop from D7
because the bishop is doing a great job
now to restricting this Knight here so I
think he could have maybe played some
other moves even King G8 just to sit on
the position to see what is the next
thing Fabiano can try to do I don't see
too many options here for him because
you don't have a before break you don't
really want to play a 5 in this position
G4 also I'm not sure because it weakens
the position so this is I think a pretty
easy way he can try to hold this
position but instead he tried to
activate the bishop and now there's some
possibilities of the F5 square and if we
go back to the the current position now
and here he misplayed it with the queen
d2 move of course and after Queen C2
Bishop D7 94 here he had to play the
smooth King G8 this is the best defense
and try to give up this E4 Pawn here not
an easy decision to make but the point
is now if you play Queen takes E4
he can he can perhaps play this move B5
to try to exchange some pounds and
if you take on B5 Bishop B5 and play the
move A4 and try to get some end game
four versus three and again this would
have been the best way for a Nepal to
play but instead he played the move F5
which I think really weakens the
position now now the Knight is going to
be extremely strong because this F5 Pawn
will be hanging in all of the variations
and Fabiano just played the correct move
Queen C7 and this is a big problem now
Knight and queen are very strong when
opponent King is weak here earlier we
didn't have that but here there are a
lot of weaknesses in a black position
now and it's going to be very difficult
to defend this position if you play
let's say King E7 loses to Knight C6 so
lose your queen immediately and you need
the way to protect your Bishop you can't
really move the bishop anywhere so you
almost have to play King gate only move
and now check on B8
if you play King E7 then you're running
into a queen E5 you're in big trouble if
you play King F7 now this
very nice book Queen d8 now putting
pressure on the bishop and very
difficult to defend this position here
F5 is hanging so suddenly a lot of
things are loose and hanging for
blackish he did have he has to play
Queen D2 check against Queen C7 and he
did and uh Fabi played by D4 E2 that is
the current position
looks like five is about to win the pawn
on B6 that's the problem how are we
going to defend the pawn on uh on B6
we've got to keep the the bishop has to
do and these are the results so far
right so far we have three draws uh
between MBL and giri Robert and Wesley
cell and Ding and doodle Ding and dude
had kicked it all off with uh but
we are expecting two wins out of the two
remaining games and if Fabi should uh
win this game it might be turning into
the All-American show as uh we would
have a clear American leader in Fabi and
Wesley started it out as being the clear
leader in the first round uh he would be
tied for second but most importantly for
Fabi he'd be kicking down a key rival in
that Ricky rival being Nepal but the
point is the move 92 really
leaves nepo in a in in a very serious
predicament the bishop on B7 needs
protection the Pawn on B6 needs
protection it's not easy to do both I
know just a few moves ago before the
time trouble yeah it looked like we
would have five draws yes and then we
came back and all of a sudden deox
position imploded as it did Napa's
position and I couldn't agree with you
more uh VAR as you were pointing out
what a strange decision right here to
play the move Knight E4 if I were in
nepo shoes and I was determined to to
play actively
you know I would have been attracted to
the Moon B5 I would love to take the
light squared Bishops off the board I'll
give up the D4 good night on F6 yeah
that's a good night on F6 and maybe even
a better night on e4 yeah then uh so if
I could get anything you know like
resembling these and
uh our number one seed
it was back to 50 and he played the move
Queen every three guys and after Queen
F3 the act just immediately resigned he
just said oh my gosh I've got no moves
and yeah we thought
uh our producer loves that Tom likes on
you I mean he's he's all over suicide
Queen F3 uh nice
nice win by farusha but maybe again
yeah the time trouble was the was the
factor there and it's been a
it's been the case for dioc the whole
time all four games all four games guys
he's been and the other two games also
it wasn't serious traveling if you
remember against Fabiano exactly he was
in a losing position as well he somehow
escaped it's it's very tough to play in
this kind of tournament against some of
the very very best players in the world
and if you're in time travel every
single game I think this is gonna make
your chances very slim to do well I know
in the previous years he did okay I
think last year actually they are
finished fourth place in this tournament
so but this year is more tough more
difficult for him
to do well and uh turning to our
remaining game as we hope to have an
interview with Ali Reza
um
Bobby said gifts Queen takes B6
uh attacking the bishop on E6 and nepo
said okay I'll defend the I'll defend
the bishop but here I've never seen such
an open invitation to trading Queens as
I see right now let's start with the
move Queen D4 please do trade queens and
the Knight takes D4 just perfectly in
time to hit the bishop extra pawn and
your idea of getting that that those
Queens off the board never look so good
uh What if black goes after the beat
Groupon by playing Queen C2 okay now
we've got this fellow on tap
uh but uh I almost feel like
no I don't have a
the one thing I don't want to allow is
something of this nature where I may be
forced to give a Perpetual check if I
have one so let's just see that one
again Queen C2 let's go take this guy
King G6 King G6
pause for just a moment because I'm
thinking I can just uh
go Queen
B6
I I I want to pin you uh what do you
think I have quintix B3 ah thank you
but you can play Queen A6
ah that was a that that shakes the
cobwebs now if you take I do have Knight
D4 and I can any checks I can go King G3
and you're forced maybe to go back right
okay
oh I want to play 26 and 94 so badly
exactly you know that this really
happened this exact kind of thing it was
a game between Granda Julio's uh Zuniga
uh from Peru and
Michael gervich
and literally there was Queen takes E6
check
Michael took the took the queen and at
the same time
said you can't move the night
the night is pinned you know so he took
the queen and he stopped it from moving
the night to Fork the king and queen
because it was illegal move and you know
you had to resign it because he gave up
the screen
and let's jump to Bucharest as Christian
is with our soul winner at least so far
of today
thanks Yasser alireza first of all
congratulations a big victory for you
yesterday you came to the studio you
seemed a little bit disappointed but
also hopeful because you felt like the
dust is off the shoulders and finally
you're starting to play some clear chest
do you feel like that yeah I think um my
as I said yesterday my game throughout
the tournament is decent level I think
just my results were not good and now
I'm happy that I got this win he's very
solid player with white and it's kind of
impossible to beat him with black and
I'm really happy to get this one
definitely a solid player but he's been
struggling in this event outside of that
minus one also his positions haven't
been that good was that part of your
strategy and did you try to complicate
matters early on in this game yeah the
last year also for instance he was in a
lot of losing position and he was
getting out of it very good he was
losing against me and he was defending
very well so that's kind of his style
and of course he has to improve still
but
um yeah for me today my plan was to just
play solid with black and yeah I didn't
try it for instance last year I played
Kingston
this year I just wanted for me draw was
okay draw was okay okay
um if he wants to force things with
white I cannot do much so let's talk
about the game because uh yeah he choose
the most solid line that there is in
love with white except she takes D5 and
I said he wants to make a quick draw but
I I played a tricky move with Bishop
before to not allow him to go for E4
which is also okay Bishop E74 because
this is your preparation without you
don't have to read I don't think it was
my I don't I just remember if there is
this possibility but I I didn't prepare
this because everything is okay here
yeah so he played this and suddenly he
got very aggressive with before but I
think it's a good move but I think there
is no need I think just rookie one Rook
D1 also but before it's a good move and
here he has to go for E4 because as we
saw in the game you know it B6 if I get
is not good then here I see I'm just
okay after it takes takes takes and
castle on 90 6p5 play normal game yeah
it's very equal so equal yeah yeah so so
he was definitely getting ambitious at
this yeah I think he just
um miscalculated something I don't know
because normally you would not go for
this one sacrifice to take it back again
and for me it was weird I think like
maybe he missed Knight B6 BC DC I don't
know yeah because normally either you go
for E4 here or you don't go to this line
to take back the opponent chorus yeah
yeah um so at this point you are already
starting to get some hopes of maybe you
know getting a game at least yeah of
course but still it was a bit risk to go
for this because I was not sure of for
instance this plan before and for
because my Bishop is on C7 it can be
dangerous e594 but I like to it I like
the fact that it's complicated so
finally we get to play some chess right
and it definitely felt that way uh let's
at this point you felt like he was
trying to find the equality in the
position but he afternoon b2a5 he got
everything got out of hand for him I
think because he missed the plan of
history but he played perfectly I think
here
Knight C5 and he color is probably here
but yeah this Knight T2 was very
important I think my only chance
and
yeah it's funny Gary it was in the city
and we were watching your game and he
was saying that you're really trying to
give back the pawn but in a creative way
to get some yeah exactly because this
Pawn was going anyway because it's not
defended by the end so yeah yeah E5 was
not so good because I missed E4 he's
he's E4 is just brilliant and I think I
have to go to take the bishop and then
push E5
and here maybe I'm better a bit but this
is still very dry it looks very yeah I
wanted to make things still complicated
but
it could have packed for it of course
thanks yeah Bishop B2 I saw I was
confused why he didn't go Bishop B2 here
actually
what okay maybe 97 yeah
takes probably missed Bishop before yeah
Queen C3 I was I was like hoping he just
doesn't go for it because so you saw
this movie yeah of course I saw this
movie because first I saw this
this line I'm just lost here 96 and
everything collapses yeah I was just
praying that there's a sequence it trade
because I bluffed the bishop before
and it works but you know practical
chess is also important right and at
this point he only had 12 minutes for a
lot of moves they left him before you
reached yeah Queen C3 is not easy not
easy yeah and you have so many moves
that you can play right maybe Queen A1
even and he was also still in the mood
to make equality I mean he was not
thinking about Advantage I think that's
a good point yeah so here Queen G5 I was
trying to be practical I was not
yeah Knights yet here he had 30 seconds
yeah yeah um I cannot explain what I
mean because he's under a lot of
pressure with time so but yeah this King
G2 Queen F3 is a solid plan yeah but he
plundered
here Rook D1
it was better
is a bit crazy to take on King G2
to
and what if before I could take
questions
yeah let's take Rook takes
could take
oh yeah it was I thought I'm winning
here but he's
oh yeah
is that it
should be streamed it should be three
not 96. yeah
years
yeah in here it's gone I think it's
already gone yeah a big victory
especially with the black pieces never
an easy uh feature uh congratulations
and good luck in the rest of your games
thank you Christian uh good luck and
Lead Ali Reza um earlier a viewer and
asked
chess and
actually yes and you just heard it
yourselves they're in that interviewer
Ali said
I bluffed I played the move Bishop F4
hoping and it's quite true
played Bishop B2 it would have been so
much easier because remember he was
playing Bishop C1 and he was kind of
flip-flopping around but Bishop B2 would
have clarified everything uh we have a
remaining game of our two tournament
co-leaders bar is uh Fabi uh making
progress
he's making some progress but it's not
so easy yeah sir I will show you a key
line here where I think he needs to find
the only move here to have a winning
chances here so this is the current
position we have Jan actually is trying
to activate that bishop and that's why
he gave up the pawn and hoping to win
the B3 Pawn here so let's take a look
now here so after King F7
um Queen D4 yeah is the best yeah
Queen C2 keeping keeping an eye on B3
and it's very important to keep this
Knight a pinned at all times so it
doesn't jump in on D4 so Queen A7 shot I
think you guys were looking at this line
King G6 Queen A6 King F7 Queen A5 Bishop
takes B3 and now black wants to play
Bishop C4 and also the A4 Pawn is
hanging so here actually if you play
King E1 just Queen D1 checking F2 will
go back to C2 so again the only move
here actually is to play Queen C3
not Queen takes F5 if you take Queen
takes F5 right then King G8
and Bishop C4 is a big problem Bishop C4
is a big problem and black is just very
very active here gotcha so for example
you can even play the move A5 Bishop C4
queen queen H5 you're you're sort of
diving but then you cannot really make
progress in this position you're like in
a permanent pin in this position right
and can't really do anything so you have
to uh give a Perpetual after let's say
F5 Queen E8 Queen G6 so that's why in
this position it's very important to
find this move here after Bishop Queen
C3 okay and now after you take on A4
then the Queens will come off the board
and this Tempo is crucial Knight D4
attacking the bishop and the pawn on F5
so white will be probably winning in
this end game so black doesn't have to
take on C3 here and can play the move
Queen A2 try to keep the queen on the
board and still threatening the move
Bishop C4 but here again another
difficult move that Fabiano needs to
find he can play five Bishop C4 he has
to play the move King G3 breaking the
pin breaking the pin if you take on E2
actually Queen takes B3 check and uh
King has to move let's say to f8 and
white is actually just winning here
Queen will go to B6
protecting the E3 Pawn King will be will
go to back to on H2 and then you
continue pushing the a pawn A5 A6 so
this is winning so
so in this position now uh Queen A2
looks like they're actually following
this position Queen A2
and um in that line if we continue
um actually
so here Queen C3 Queen A2
King G3 and uh Bishop takes A4 so this
is your chance to eliminate the pawn
before pawn reaches A5 Queen C7 check
King G6
and Knight C3 here
attacking the queen and a bishop and
again the line continues
Queen B3 Queen D6 check
King H7 you capture on A4 and after
Queen D5 you're gonna be winning this F5
yes
wow
this is I think very good winning
chances because the E4 Pawn is going to
be really weak after you capture the F5
Pawn wow this is not easy not at all uh
in fact that's uh that's some some some
very very serious work uh as we get
prepared for break just to give me your
intuition is this game going to be our
second decisive game or yes yes it'll be
okay okay well that would give us a
clear leader as we go on break uh
Christian caught up with some uh fans in
the playing Hall I think you're going to
enjoy uh the upcoming special
[Music]
we are here with Anna and Elisa Anna
Eliza welcome to the show tell us a bit
about how are you feeling to see all
these great players here the world
champion is here in Bucharest how do you
feel about that
enthusiastic we are excited I'm quite
nervous actually it's my first time
going to such a big event and
we can't wait to see what happens next
when did you guys start playing chess
uh she's more into chess than me yeah
she just kind of accompanies me oh I
started playing like one year ago and
what would you say was your uh favorite
player as you were picking up chess
oh that's
her famous you know YouTube the big
husband chess
um it's hard to pick
um I'd say Chicago
okay yeah yeah I watch him on streams
sometimes very cool very cool and how
about the Queen's Gambit did you guys
see that show
I wanted to see it I think I'm going to
see it it's like twice or three times
I'm not sure it was amazing I loved it
yeah yeah and from this tournament who
is your favorite player who do you think
is going to win this tournament I'm not
sure we'll see what's um what happens
next honestly
yeah yeah
um I saw that he was like one phone up
and I was like oh this is us
we're getting a lot of Nepal fans here
what is it about nepo what attracts you
to his playing style
um I'm not sure what to say about that
I don't think I can say anything about
the playing style but I think he's a
good player I mean I saw that he was
against dingler and you know the world
championship and yeah
yeah well guys thank you very much for
uh joining us Anna Eliza go enjoy the
show
Jason St Louis is back with nine major
tournaments throughout the year it all
kicks off in March with the second
edition of the American cup with 16
players across two Fields fighting for a
300 thousand dollar prize fund in this
double elimination tournament with both
classical and Rapid time controls for
the first time since 2020 the Cairns cup
is Back featuring the world's best
female chess players competing for a 180
000 prize fund beginning June 3rd
seasonal Classic Events are back
starting with the spring chess Classic
on April 5th the summer chess classic
August 2nd followed up with the St Louis
Norm Invitational and the winter chess
classic wraps up the year in December
September brings back everyone's
favorite chess night Alex where some of
the world's best don't even know what's
coming and compete for a 150 000 prize
fund 30 players across three Fields come
together in St Louis for the U.S juniors
girls and Senior championships starting
July July 15th in partnership with us
chess the best in the U.S fight to be
the nation's best and a four hundred
thousand dollar prize fund in October as
the U.S and U.S women's championships
takes place in the chess capital of
America a year full of action-packed
Chess is just getting started all
broadcasts are available on our St Louis
chess club YouTube and twitch.tv
channels
thank you
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
thank you foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
chess classic from Bucharest Romania we
have four results yes we had one win
today by our capsid firusha with the
black pieces and three draws between MPL
and Geary Rapport and Wesley and Ding
and doodle well the remaining game
features a matchup between two of our
tournament co-leaders coming in today's
competition we had a quad four players
tied for first including the man you're
looking at are sitting on stage Bobby
his opponent nepo came in with a plus
one score and at the moment well what to
say two extra pawns for white should be
winning is it going to be difficult for
Fabi to convert uh VAR
um it's not so easy to win I mean I
think you should be able to convert this
Advantage into a win but we can take a
look at some of the lines at some point
yes sir he needs to sacrifice one of the
pawns to get rid of this pin this
unpleasant pin so uh of the night only
two so okay let's go back here to the
current position so King h8 is just
played again if you get rid of this pin
and put a knight on D4 you'll be just
simply winning but it's not so easy to
do that so I think he needs to start
with the move B4 in this position you
can give a check but after King H7 it
you don't really make any progress so
you need to come back Queen A5 so B4 is
necessary so if he plays that then
Bishop C4 right very logical move
putting pressure on the on the Knight
and now Queen d8 check King H7
Queen D1 defend the night defends the
pawn exactly and now A4 Pawn is also
defended if you take only two I think
this end game is Just
gonna be very very comfortable here you
can play Queen B2 or queen C4 so you
have really good winning chances here
because there are a lot of Pawns on the
board so it's going to be hard to
generate a Perpetual ideas here
Perpetual checks so for example Queen to
be fine
F5 Pawn once again it's a pocket yeah
yeah F5 Pawn once again is a big problem
so black shouldn't take on E2 okay in
this position so let's go back
[Music]
um
in this position so Bishop D3
he can just play Bishop B3 here and the
question is now how to get rid of this
pin here so you have to continue with B5
okay try to advance the pawn
and now Queen B2
so we're a little stuck yes again if we
if we play King E1 there is a queen B4
check so we're not really making much
progress so we have to play the move B6
okay to sacrifice the pawn and now if
you take on B6 then finally we can put
this Knight on D4 then we're very happy
here because the pressure on F5 and with
the a pawn this should be winning here
it's like plus four here white now it's
surprising looking at this line and I
can sit
high and far it says plus four when we
only have one Pawn well two at the
moment right yeah
it still says plus four I know that can
be really disconcerting and uh the line
actually continues here guys Bishop A6
if black says you know I don't want to
take this Pawn I just want to keep this
pin and now you play A5
uh it seems like you should be just
winning your pastor just keep
progressing but it's still it's still
not easy to untangle here so for example
Bishop D3 okay and now again we have um
uh different ideas we can try to do
again B7 is one option
Queen takes and I finally get the Knight
on D4
and queen B2 check
we can play King G1 or King G3 and this
should be winning now right so this is
the the main idea how Fabi should try to
win this game by advancing the pawn
eventually sacrificing one pawn and
putting the Knight on default thank you
for let's take a sneak peek at what we
can expect tomorrow before the rest day
right so we'll see new promise you again
special agrath do that against Fabi
very interesting match up there so
against diak okay maybe opportunity for
Wesley and fury against Robert
nice matchups absolutely I really like
that idea of what you were saying from
the current position played the move B4
and go Queen d8 check and queen D1 I
think that that that that that makes it
very very clean and it's very clear what
you have to do I think at this moment
because we have one remaining game it's
nice to give a shout out to our audience
and say we enjoyed
you're testing panel and uh we invite
you to get to join the conversation and
you can send your tweets or right
suggestions tweets using hashtag super
bad chess classic or you can send your
questions via YouTube or twitch on St
Louis chess collab Channel right now of
our uh we had had this question earlier
from the audience about whether or not
there was luck in chess and while there
isn't that much luck yes there is we had
it today
when uh faroujee came on with Christian
and he said I bluffed a little bit with
the move Bishop F4 that I bluffed if you
don't mind bringing up that particular
game and that particular moment because
did you catch what he was saying as to
what it was that he had bluffed had he
bluffed Bishop B2 or something
yeah I think this is the position where
he played the move Bishop Bishop F4 here
right let's take a look what else I
could have done so engines like the idea
of Queen takes D4 but I think he never
really wanted to exchange the Queens
because of the clock situation and
knowing that the ACT is probably gonna
burn more time here so the move Bishop
F4 here played here
and uh so Queen C3 was played so he's
he's attacking The Rook on uh C1 right
and the problem now if you take on d8
Rook takes d8 there is a background
problem here uh yeah sir you don't have
the move Rook C2 the desired move Rook
C2 to keep the control of the C4 square
and you have to move the Rook somewhere
and then you're gonna run into some
problems with the move uh Knight C4
right so that's that's why he played the
move Bishop F4 here objectively again
this position is actually slightly
better
for white after the move Bishop F4 and
the Ark played the correct move Queen uh
no actually he didn't he didn't play
Queen City Queen C3 would have been a
best move perhaps this is where things
started to go slightly wrong for him
when you move the Rook up and remember
in the rest of the game he always had
some background problems in this game
here right so how do you play the move
Queen C3 here attacking the queen let's
say queen G5 and now you just put the
Rook not on C2 but on a very stable
Square on B1 and you're never gonna have
any problems on a background it's going
to be protected and I think uh I don't
see how black can win this position
because G3 is coming up you still have
the weaknesses on C6 and A5 in fact
white is slightly better there
so the bluff paid off uh thanks to the
time trouble and here we are looking at
Fabi and the current time
is is that accurate so nepo has 32
minutes let's say and Fabi has 11 and
20. but did he already get his 30 minute
increase yes he did he did so that's it
he's not getting any more time and I
think Bobby's doing the right thing by
taking a long thing here because this is
the critical moment if he finds the main
idea of putting the queen on D1 yes and
throwing the B Pawn yes Back to Black
and then free in the night from the pin
with Knight D4 from there he won't need
much time to convert that game exactly
using the pawn as a decoy and from this
current position this is uh where it
kind of looks a little bit
counter-intuitive to play the move B B3
B4 because it's almost like oh the one
thing I shouldn't allow is the move
Bishop C4 because then the queen and the
bishop are nicely coordinating and
suddenly white no white is not in
trouble in fact move B4 is really good
because as VAR was saying what you
should be willing to do is your two
pawns up give one of them back yeah just
drop back with the queen it defends the
Knight it defends the bishop and if you
try to maintain this uh pin if you will
uh like this I'm going to use the pawn
eventually as a decoy uh to to get you
um off the pin also once once we get
into these types of positions with the
pawns so Advanced I'm always starting to
think I could just give up the night and
Away you go exactly so the the
sometimes you have to overcome your
reluctance to play a move like before
because you see Bishop C4 and you go why
should I give my opponent this kind of
counter play do you think VAR that
that's what Fabi is dealing with that he
has to allow Bishop C4 that he he wants
to win the game cleaner if you will
absolutely I think he's feeling that he
should be winning here and he's trying
to work out the lines where he doesn't
have to play this move but he has been
spending about 10 minutes already on the
clock and he's getting low at the moment
so he really needs this move before to
win the game I don't see any others
moves or Alternatives he's he's got nine
minutes right now so he needs to he
needs to go for it uh you know hopefully
he sees this idea of before and then
transferring the queen to D1
um otherwise I think Ian is just gonna
pick up the pawn on B3 and uh he's gonna
have a really good drawing chances here
well okay so before you showed me the
move before before you you showed me B4
and queen D1 the moves that were going
through my mind
was this idea that yes I should use my
queen side as a decoy but to do it in
this way
so what I was thinking was that in
whenever you play Queen takes B3 uh my
knight is released I'll go Knight D4 you
mentioned yourself your King on H2 is
very sweet you know very safe and if I
could get you to play Bishop takes B3
well now I was happy because I could
play Queen takes F5 check
etc etc so my
thought process because I wasn't on the
B4 Queen D1 I was thinking I would go
Queen f8
is that uh good or bad uh Queen afraid
is actually another alternative you can
definitely play like this and this will
most likely lead to a position where we
will have Queens left on the board and
four pawns versus three uh so in this
position
um after Queen fa the best uh tries
Queen takes B3 okay Knight to D4 Knight
to D4
and queen takes A4 okay and if you take
the bishop there's a queen A2 check and
queen will pick up the bishop only six
which I don't want of course and then
you will yeah you will have to play
Knight X F5 okay and uh you have we have
black has to take the Knight on F5
otherwise it's just completely lost okay
um and then Queen takes a five check
King h8 and this same game is uh it's
it's around plus two for white but with
the Queens on the board and now we see
Fabiano is
clock is still ticking and he hasn't
moved yet right I'm not sure how easy to
win this queen end game because it's
gonna be a lot more difficult with the
Queens on the board you always have to
watch for the checks exact Perpetual
ideas and sometimes even with two extra
pawns it's not that trivial that you're
gonna win the game here so I think this
is not an easy win in this position here
exactly uh you had shown also well uh
Queen d8 are we gonna see B4 you'd shown
also a previously A variation where you
got this Queen and four versus queen and
three as well
Fabi played Queen d a check
so King H7 will be playing instantly
rather instantly which in fact now let's
see what he wants to do here
Queen A5 he's repeating it yeah my guess
is gonna push before right away now yeah
after King age eight okay uh because
Bobby came on our show yesterday and in
his game with mvl he said well he had
expected mdl not to play the move Queen
H3 when he played 92 resigns he expected
mvl to centralize his Queen and he was
going to repeat once and then decide how
he was going to play so
um
definitely Fabi is one of those players
who enjoys uh
repeating at least once not necessarily
to gain time on the clock although there
is that factor the jurors
remind your opponent like I'm the one
dictating I'll be telling us when you
know we're going to be making it just a
little victories exactly and we live for
those small tiny uh moments but Bobby
doesn't look like he's completely at
ease sure I mean before Sims so
unnatural to allow opponent to play
Bishop C4 yeah B3 B4 allowing your
opponent uh you're you're in this pin
which is never easy but then to allow
the one remaining appease that your
opponent has to hit that pin piece but
it's all about the timing and in this
case the queen comes back perfectly in
time to defend both uh the Knight as
well as the pawn and then as we've been
discussing use one of the pawns on the
queen side is a decoy to break the pin
so you get to play Knight D4 and
eventually win uh six minutes six min
it's uh kind of a nervy sign yeah he
needs to make that decision
what for you is time trouble like you
look at you you're sitting there happily
playing the game there's 15 moves to
make for the time control right you're
gonna get your bonus yay
and you look over the clock
you're not nervous because it says 10.
right you're not nervous because it says
six
are you nervous when it says four when
do you get nervous five five me too it's
five exactly my brain switches oh it
says Blitz now no it's scary and
switching from classical to Blitz
in the middle of the game is a very
difficult thing to do true and you
immediately feel the butterflies and the
nerves and starting to it's that five
minute it's that five minute Mark for
you VAR when do you feel that added
tension of the clock when it hits three
when it hits two when it hits five I
think it's also depending on a position
yes or if position is complicated then
I'm a lot more worried yeah but if it's
like a simpler position I see it's a
technical end game I can try to play the
moves by intuition it's a little bit
different but I would say yeah when I
get to below let's say three minutes
it's I'm already concerned yeah and when
we're talking complicated position too
yeah I need to simplify it I look ways
to simplify the position if if I don't
see anything concrete that I can do
definitely not I don't try to complicate
more than it already is the position
well we're seeing four and a half
minutes and the clock is ebbing away I
tell you when that clock does reach that
moment bit of danger it does feel like
the seconds fly faster it's the craziest
thing uh and you're also just not used
to making moves quickly right like
physics
and yeah it will affect the rest of your
moves yeah
which which came from the tournament did
somebody forgot their clock we said no
it was dingler in in the world
championship match against nepo he just
like it was crazy we're watching the
game we're watching it dude move dude
move move move and then panic and
collapse and ding lost that game uh what
what are you expecting at this exact
moment bar I know the engine has been
harping on B3 B4 but Fabi still doesn't
look like he's ready to make that
commitment yeah I think the more he
thinks I think less likely he will play
this movie yesterday and I I'm afraid I
don't see any other way he can try to
play for a win in this position so I
think Giannis Young's chances are
getting
increasing right of trying to hold this
game and uh but there is really no other
Alternatives because if you just play a
movie like Queen C3 here opponent will
take the pawn on B3 and you play A5 and
again Bishop comes into C4 anyway and
then you only have one Pawn left and
you're still under that pin right so
again that idea is very important as you
mentioned and I did earlier just today
wow wow it took him almost 12 minutes
including a repetition
to build up The Bravery of B3 B4 but he
did overcome
this reluctance to allow the bishop to
C4 and that's again
um
calculation yes he is a great calculator
he trusts himself that he can finish
this game with just three minutes on the
clock I know and that's that's
confidence yeah that's nervy but b3b4
indeed is on the board and we've been
talking about Bishop C4 Queen uh d8 by
the way where is nepo yeah and it's
nowhere to be fun yeah yeah yeah it's
pacing yeah
yeah I think there's a well Christian
hasn't taken us to the VIP room where
the players likely have snacks and
drinks so we expect I suspect he's
hiding out there for the Moment by the
way when my opponent gets into time
trouble I like leaving but most of the
time I like sitting at the board but I
like leaving the board and letting them
get nervous and using their clock but B3
B4 on the board and why do we like this
move because once again there is this
nice move Queen D1 oops excuse me that
is a mouse slip from yours truly but
Queen D1 defends uh the Knight defends
the pawn and yes we can get into a queen
upon end game of five versus four but as
VAR made it very clear this is an ending
where your chances of making a Perpetual
check against White's King are close to
zero
which is a bad sign and in the meanwhile
your queen will eventually have to take
up a very passive Square I'll tuck my
king over to H2 and eventually I'll play
Queen to C5 and drive your queen away uh
nepo is back
with us and he's seen the move of B3 B4
you know it's funny uh do you think that
this move Kim is a surprise
to Nepal I think he was hoping that
Fabio wouldn't go for it
that he had that he was aware of it and
he's just like don't play it don't play
it yeah just you're in time trouble
let's just make a draw right right how
about you VAR do you think nepo was
aware of this move I think so I think he
was aware of it and again when Bobby was
spending a lot of time he was hoping
maybe he would do something different
right but now he can actually try to
make things a little bit more difficult
for Fabi to bring this queen to D1 he
can play this move Queen C2
Queen C2 yes the idea that you when you
play Queen D check in H7 you don't have
this move Queen D1 anymore okay and here
actually uh uh Fabi has to find the
another move here because Bishop C4 is a
massive threat yes and here actually
very very important after Queen City
that you have this move B5
okay Bishop C4 you have this E1 Square
for the queen to go to it looks really
bad you're completely pinning yourself
but again you're gonna put the pawn on
B6 and you're using on A5 yeah you're
using uh it is a decoy to break the pin
yes if y loses both A and B pawns then
that end game I mean why it's better but
if the Knight is on D4 and I capture F5
okay so we take F5 for A and B exactly
then I think that's something we can
work with but Queen C2 that is a
because again it's not an intuitively
obviously uh
an obvious uh B5 Queen E1 yeah and Ken
white play Quincy five here with the
idea that on Bishop C4 I can give check
on the last Rank and take on a five with
a check yes and then okay so you won a
pawn with a check I'm I'm more than
eager to make a draw so go ahead and
take a Perpetual how are you going to
defend this Knight it's a good question
you could check me
I have Queen G4 but I'm afraid of each
one yeah you you can count on H5 and by
the way you went for Bishop C4 directly
which does allow Queen D1 which you know
oh boy was he happy zero for white yes
Bobby was very happy that move Queen C2
was was asking more pertinent questions
but I do like B5 and queen E1 but we do
have our our position after all
yeah
the players of doing a great job at
following
the analysis so what if black plays H5
H4 with the idea that when we reach that
Queen end game when you wanted to hide
your King on H2 made it I would have
some Queen G3 Perpetual ideas so like
something like this couldn't be too
maybe it is right I don't know I'm just
I'm putting up the position not
necessarily uh how we get there but
something like this and so you like the
pawn on H4 B7 okay
oh
so what are we going to do with black
Bishop D3 yay sure okay so we throw the
pawn to B7 yeah I take
Queen takes B7 yeah I put the Knight on
D4 at last
ah
G6
okay you could have thrown in check I
don't know if how pertinent it is the
queen on A1 now
or B3 yeah I was kind of still going in
this Direction one of the problems is
that maybe my knight
could be with you know nasty chat
meeting you know your your king doesn't
have too much shelter going on over
there the blank knits is the queen on C1
but yeah getting there yeah okay uh
Queen B3 okay well let's do it right
let's let's try to get the queen on uh
come too slow you can play 96. can I
yeah yes because Queen B7 should be
Checkmate yes indeed
right I just come right over gotcha so
96 yeah I guess
G6 exposure lifting your kimono he
exposed uh
Bishop C4
uh Queen B1
um we need we need nepo needs help bar I
gotta call a friend here tell us what
Netbook it is H5 H4
um you can try H5 H4 definitely but in
the line that you guys were looking at
it pretty much at some point You're
Gonna Lose That H4 Pawn okay and uh but
he can try to make things more difficult
Fabi has about four minutes on the clock
uh let's let's take a look the exact how
this line can follow after H5 so right
white can play B5
and now if you play H4 right
you can just play B6
and the idea is to play Queen E1 now and
also play the move A5 to secure the pawn
so let's say if you play Queen B2 okay
A5
Bishop to D3 and right around here when
the bishop is already on D3 you can play
the move B7
and if you take the pawn
again we see this idea it's like a theme
of this position as soon as the queen is
moved you put the Knight on D4 sorry
about actually what if I take the Knight
first on E2 uh after after B7 right okay
so let's say if you take care Queen
takes E2
Queen takes B7
and here's I think uh Queen takes a two
threatening to play A6 so let's say I
play Queen Queen A6 yes and I think this
again the problem is this F5 Pawn it's
just too weak here so you can start with
the move Queen D5 putting pressure on F5
Queen C8
and here's I think we're gonna be able
to win the H4 Pawn in this queen in game
so we can start with the move A6
so I don't have time for Queen C2 and no
I think Queen C2
King G1
Queen C1
King H2 Queen takes E3 now of course
you're threaten Queen G3 Queen E1
Perpetual but then Queen F5 check
King goes to G8
now Queen's Queen D5 check
King H7 and just pick up the HP yeah
Queen H5 and pick up the point what if I
played King f8
so putting a Pawn on H4 it's it's fixing
uh wise position a little bit but also
at the end of the day it's gonna be easy
target for white to win it right I just
like the fact that behind you you're
seeing this plus two plus three and then
it went to plus 10 and plus 60. like
right now behind you plus 60 you know is
uh occurred uh so that's rather
definitive uh good play will get uh a
stone cold win and again Fabi winning
this game and going to plus two
sure so later but it's sort of like
Bobby you know he's been working on his
game in terms of of
um bringing as rapid and Blitz to a
higher level I mean before he had been
like solely concentrating on his
classical chess and then you saw his
classical chess rating go down as his uh
as his Blitz rating went up and a
reminder how uh Favi got here I we
thought he might have missed a one in
round one yes he missed a win in round
one then he had a quick draw against
thing in round two well prepared drawing
might even imagine well prepared and a
quick win yesterday against them
miniature I I asked Fabby when was the
last time he won in let's say 25 moves
or less and he paused he said classical
right you know yeah classical and he
still paused it's been a while but he
did win a miniature and today if he were
to win against nepo he'd really be
feeling uh great
um
sorry I wanted to ask is there a way
that net you you showed us a moment ago
where nepo could have maybe played Queen
C2 instead of uh the the move that he
played Bishop C4 uh
is there some way that he can throw
through Fabi a complicated
how could he make life difficult for
Fabi can he in the current position yes
uh let's take a look so what are the
options here again we looked at the H5
and we kind of get it's the same idea we
just start pushing the b-pawn here
um
there are not that many Alternatives
because our plan is very simple
I have one crazy idea please so G5
yeah
the coach looking at the star player and
saying what are you doing what are you
doing putting up launching a
three-pointer from the half court I have
nothing to lose G5 here yes yes
I I've I'm behind you go go G5 okay um
and B5 if we continue I take on F4 this
i o pen one diagonal I'm with you
something you're my hero
Queen B2 just to get that because that
that way you can't play B6 as a decoy
because you could actually take it with
a check so Queen B2 here uh
oh no our Bishop is hanging yeah we have
to start with King G6 prophylaxis move
King G6
and now we just continue with the
planets as before
okay Bishop A6
five
and the open diagonal doesn't benefit me
in any way well I mean but you no no I'm
I'm warming up to what you're doing
because at least you've got a passer in
the position Bishop takes E2
Queen takes A5 I mean at least you're
kicking here somehow aren't we or is it
five check
but the king is now now if I also had a
Pawn on H4 I would feel happier okay but
Queen C5 check he can't go to G3 because
of Queen E3 check he has to go to F1
then I try to hide on H2 again
okay is there any way we can use our E3
Pawn so Quincy for check
King G1 Pony E3
are we just one Temple behind no
unfortunately
uh in E2 as we see uh reaching for
something something
Bishop B3
okay
doesn't feel particularly uh
it wasn't that crazy no no no no no no I
mean uh compared to everything else yeah
it did for you right that was but no it
wasn't the shock
bavar had this look like
you know I mean uh you like you dribbled
the ball out of bounds or something no
that was great I have to admit G5 is
actually it's it's It's Tricky it's
challenging well that's what I was
saying you know I'm trying to what is
there a way of making Fabi work hard yes
and by the way after Bishop B3 Fabby
said just a second just a second that F5
Pawn is your problem let me go after it
Queen D7 and Eon quickly dropped his
Bishop back
to E6 now that the pawns on B4
can we just simply play Queen B5 and
just say hey your Bishop can't move
because of the F5 bone absolutely now
it's just the evaluation jumped and it's
almost plus six now for Fabi if he finds
the move Queen B5 yeah there is one line
that he needs to just calculate after
that so let's take a look Queen B5 yeah
and so now if you play Bishop C4 then F5
is hanging with the check so it will be
the same thing check and we already seen
this position but actually we just won
the pawn on F5 so we go Queen D7 check
and we just come back to D1 so it's a
better version that we're getting here
so and you found it Abby quickly played
Queen B5 by the way I mean his somehow
this Pawn on B3 magically moved to B4
and it's uh can you go back to the same
idea of Queen C2 here yeah Queen C2 in
this position now you're threatening
Bishop C4 but here actually the Knight
is already protected so you can simply
play the move
and Bishop C4 we have Queen F5 check but
again the line continues there is uh for
example a move uh not not Queen D3 sir
Queen D2 okay and here uh you just play
King H2 simply putting your king to
safety you ignore the fact that he can
take your Pawn but then you play the
move Queen E5
centralizing the queen and protecting
the F4 Pawn if you move the bishop I
just play Knight G3 and I have Knight H5
ideas that's amazing on G7 and if you
take only two the queen end game is just
simply hopeless because F5 Pawn is
hanging with a check and then we just
continue advancing our A and B pawns so
you can play E3 just to go a little bit
deeper on this line Queen F5 check King
a shade and we can just play B5 and the
fact that we're gonna Queen with a check
is going to make a very big difference
here truly it's strange black pawn looks
much closer to promotion than lights and
yet it's not it is not the clay case
it's more about King safety
than than the faster Pawn uh Queen B5 uh
very powerful setup here that was uh
this is the current position we were
looking at Queen C2
oh dear oh dear
yeah Fabi found Queen B5 so quickly I
think he spent 10 seconds or so
one of the things that was very
different in my day is we had a Germans
and those adjourned so we had these five
hour playing sessions we would stop for
a few hours or even an entire day and
resume the adjournment and I always
thought the end game play was really
remarkably good and you could see that
for example Anatoly karpov was just a
fantastic end-game player because of the
adjournments you could study the end
games these guys play from the opening
to a finish yeah and some of their end
games are simply excellent like like
Flawless and it it's shocking to me to
see today's players playing endgame so
well
without the Germans no they have to they
that's how they've been trained yeah
yeah that's the level of that these
players are competing at right now uh
for yourself or in your career you did
you play also a germ Physicians or it
was just fading uh yeah it was just
fading I've had maybe one or two a
German games in uh late 90s I think
right and I think pretty much early
2000s they already did they were
completely were gone once the computers
got better so I had a few adjourned
games here in my career right
but but you hear what I'm saying there
is that that is a German that's allowed
us to really work out the end games to a
Precision absolutely analyze deeper and
try to get more ideas in a few German
games ahead I remember analyzing with my
coach this was back in Armenia and
trying to find the uh you know winning
or defensive ideas to try to save the
game I have a question yes sir so during
those adjournments was it allowed to get
help from other people yeah so the fact
uh most of my Soviet opponents actually
came with an Entourage like it was very
common to see uh
uh carp off with bad guys or zaitsev or
somebody was with him or even a group of
people and one of the most extraordinary
things I have ever seen was during the
world championship match in Murano in
1981 was one of those buses those
massive massive buses came and it was
the Soviet delegation arriving and
Michael Steen and I counted 37 Samsonite
suitcases
like how many persons
came and just for carp off and it was
like it was Michael myself love Goodman
uh Petra Victor and that was our team it
was like oh my gosh were we were we out
there seven that sounds like too many
cooks in the kitchen yeah and that
sometimes is a problem but yes uh you
were allowed to have a a second a
trainer or more
and uh
we do have some moves by the way King h8
just Queen C5 getting
the queen away from the bishop C4
yeah Fabi didn't play that uh King G1
idea to get rid of the pin but the queen
C5 is still very good yeah he's looking
like Bishop C4 is going to be met by
Queen check so that you could pick up
this Pawn on F5 with a check
and anytime this pin is released Knight
D4 is an automatic answer so Queen takes
A4 be my guest munch on that pawn Knight
to D4 one of a a surprising uh uh I was
in it was the last round of a tournament
in lemares Spain
and I had an adjournment I was black
against Anatoly karpov
and if I make a draw Boris basket is the
winner of the competition
so I was very confident in my analysis
and I I was a little bit worse let's say
against karpov but I was pretty sure I I
had analyzed it well there was a knock
on the door opened up the door and
there's Boris basket yeah sir how are
you fine how was your position with
karpov yes I think it's a draw can I
help you it's not necessary all right
have a good evening and that's all it
was it was a very short very sweet
conversation thank you Boris uh for
offering me help
then as I closed the door and went back
and I was thinking about it well Boris
was from the Soviet Union there was that
it's only car problem from the Soviet
Union the Russian the Soviet Ambassador
was in the playing hall waiting for the
game to resume it was like wait a minute
you know the Soviets were sending me a
Soviet guy to help me it was it was a
little bit uh messed up but and the game
was a draw and
um
Boris baskey won the tournament
maybe they were just checking if you
knew that it was a draw I don't know I
don't know they wanted some Intel from
you I know yeah like what could it be
but uh yeah Queen C5 uh good move yes uh
second best move here and uh White is
white is just winning again if you take
the pawn on A4 the Knight will jump in
on D4 exactly so I think Jana is going
to try to play
G6 he's looking for some kind of trick
to protect F5 so he can he can threaten
the move Bishop C4 but let's take a look
if he plays G6 for example looks like he
wants to do that and actually
um
this is a little bit different idea now
we're gonna see you can still put you
can still play the move B5 okay
um so that in this position but you also
have another alternative here you can
play the move King E1 now King Edgar
watch yes well just Defending Your
Knights too and now you're getting ready
to play the move Knight D4 and if Queen
A1 check is played you actually can play
the move Knight C1 here Knight okay
that's a different setup yes and now
everything is protected if you take on
A4 I have a queen E5 check picking up
the bishop only six that's and if you
play something like kng8 I can just
continue pushing my a pawn everything is
protected there's no checks even in this
position yeah
no that's yeah that yeah that's fair and
he has played G7 G6 yeah you just played
G6 and uh
and to hear King E1 could be uh the most
precise way uh Fabi can win this game
but he can also he can also play the
move uh B5
it's another alternative because Bishop
C4 check and then he will go back to
this line with the queen on D1
ah it's so simple Queen D4 check and
queen D1 once again somehow we've gotten
into that same setup but this time we've
been induced removed G7 G6 which may be
out actually helpful for white as it
makes Black's uh King that much more
vulnerable so G7 G6 okay things are
getting desperate that is down to one
minute and 40 seconds any place can get
one can get one nice
by the way again very nice that uh you
know you you've been thinking about King
G3 for so long and
and we all love a safe King so King H2
is like the natural drawing that's the
magnetic square that we want to move the
king to so you're again you're
overcoming your natural desire to play
your king to safety King E1
so I explain like an engine not like a
human I know
uh there was some there was some match
that I I saw I think it was from the TP
Sigma tournament that is actually
ongoing now our big shout out to Mishra
and Peter's Fiddler who tied for first
but uh there was one game that was
played almost with absolute perfect
accuracy I was like wow it was so
impressive King E1 uh accurate play was
it Mishra
sorry I forgot who the players were yeah
but uh yeah you know our colleague
Peters Fiddler uh in studio and he's
always he's in studio and Peter is is he
just loves beating himself up oh I'm so
awful I'm so terrible I'm so awful you
put him in a competition and he's in
first you know like what and if you won
a World Cup twice yes yes yes yes yes uh
King E1 and we have King G8 on the board
it
so both Kings come into the city
but is it time
are we finally ready for Knight D4 or is
it should we just push the pawns should
we just push the pawns yeah
and actually 94 is is good you can also
try to play Queen D6 if you want to be a
little bit more precise to put pressure
on G6 okay but 94 works and uh there is
really with a knight on the floor
there's no really Perpetual ideas or
anything black can try to do if 94 and
queen A1 would we bring the king more
towards the center to D2
uh if 94 let's say Bishop C4 we do have
by the way Queen D6 it's just said it
you know to be a little bit more precise
you know you're putting pressure on the
G6 Pawn by the way just you know a
moment ago I believe said put your
knight on C1 and even at the cost of the
G2 Pawn you know somehow you know
getting your knight on C1 your Pawn on
A5 everything is super protected uh I
found that
very attractive to my eyes uh Queen D6
on the board
that's why I was asking if we put the
Knight on D4 then we don't have Knight
C1 anymore correct so yes that line if
you put a knight on D4 instead of Queen
D6 Bishop C4 comes in and you can just
continue playing B5 because there are as
I mentioned there are really no threats
uh there if you play Queen uh A1 check
just King goes back to F2 there is a
queen F1 check but I just go to G3 and
uh Queen E1 check King G1 and you cannot
take on a trip because the C4 Bishop is
hanging with the check
so yeah I think it's we're getting very
close here uh for Fabi to win and King
F7 played and now I think after it's
time to activate that night that we've
been waiting for for a long long time I
mean the patience of a sphinx
94 is just gonna it's very natural now
to play this move Bishop is under attack
Bishop C4 probably will be played and
again there are no threats here the way
that the white pieces are set up
everything is protected you just
continue pushing the beep on here with
B5 there is nothing really you need to
even calculate or worry about and just
just to be 6b7 will win the game for
Fabiano
nice I love this Knight on D4 and
getting uh the pawn to B5 just as you've
prescribed it uh and I can't help but
looking behind you and see us the plus
seven uh going there so uh Bobby uh is
doing well but now it's all about the
clock because uh he's got this winning
position but at the same time he's got
well with that move he's got uh
48 seconds but he was going down to 20
there for a moment
uh I don't like this move guys Queen D2
you don't like no he's just gave up the
a pawn I mean it's still winning it
wasn't necessary he could have played A5
he couldn't have played A5 he could play
Knight E4 I could have played B5 and
it's still winning I think he's gonna
play the move Queen B2 now and just to
cut off all the squares but again it's
just uh it was not necessary to allow
this uh still winning so let's take a
look Queen takes A4
now he will play Queen B2 this way now
everything is under control and the
Knight is going to go to D4 so
it still feels pretty good yes yeah it's
still pretty good I mean the best move
here is actually Cooney too but I think
that end game is hopeless should be just
hopeless here but if you keep the Queens
on the board I think it will make things
even easier for why because he will
continue uh with the Knight D4 B5 and uh
this this should be just winning here uh
Bishop C4 we can check here for example
Knight D4
what we have on the board Queen takes A4
Knight D4 plate okay yeah
and the idea is to play B5 of course
exactly Queen B2 Queen A1 check if black
tries to activate the queen just King
will simply go to F2 here yeah this is
what we've been trying to achieve for
the better part of the last hour or so
is our night is no longer pinned and
we're gonna go B5 yeah or or even here
if you play Bishop C4 just Knight C6 and
now getting ready to play Queen D7 and
organize an attack with the queen and
Knight here that could be a check mating
attack and if you try to play Bishop D3
then at least you have few different
options 95 check picking up the bishop
on D3 and two extra pawns that should be
winning yeah uh B5 is winning as well
here
so
still winning for Fabiano but he's he's
got a minute on the clock and again
until uh the game is completely over
right you know you you still have to be
alert to make sure the move Bishop C4
did not
catch Fabi unawares on the contrary uh
Fabi the moment he saw Bishop to C4 by
nepo King F2 instantly we're talking
about the safety of that H2 Square sort
of like a magnet if you can put your
King on F2 and we've been talking about
this forever butcher Queen on B2 your
Pawn on B5
it's it's it's game over so King F2 uh
everything's going still according to
plan yes yeah it's still uh completely
winning for white but uh
and very difficult to prevent this B5
moves so you can try to play Queen A6
okay for example and then we have the
move Queen B2 love that move getting
ready to play B5 Queen is very well
placed here
um
you can try maybe bishop B5 just just to
prevent sure but here black and white
can actually just improve the position
of the king king first go away from the
Chase and eventually uh bring the queen
into the game here so with
Bishop C4 oh well that allows me that
allows me okay King E7 King E7 for
example do you want to improve the
position more with King HD yeah I can go
I can go Queen B3 threatening uh Queen
G8 and forcing you to play the move
Bishop C4 and then
Queen to C3 now if the bishop moves away
I can enter on the C file and you're
threatening B5 as well this is nasty
it's terrible yeah if let's say H5 we
have B5 Bishop takes B5 check Queen C5
check will win the game
oops sorry that's the mouse slip
so H5 just play by nepo and let's see
so H5 King G3 very deeply on the board
and thanks to these last three moves by
Fabi at a moment where I started to get
a little concerned for his clock he was
down to about 20 seconds he's now even
close to two
thanks to these very very rapid last few
moves and I like this move King G3 a lot
uh Queen B2 and B5 is not going away
for white yes at some point uh if it's
an end game you can even go King H4 King
G5
so that's another way that you can try
to win the game if let's say the Queens
are off the board you can even enter
with the King now so
and you also prevent black from putting
the pawn on H4 which sometimes will give
him some uh you know ideas for the pope
for the Perpetual yeah so King G3 is a
great move and almost two minutes for
Fabiano versus
about a little bit less than 10 for Yan
here
uh I know as we came on the air of our
you gave a head to head between Fabi and
nepo could you just remind me as well as
our viewers how they match up uh
prior to today's game
yeah let's let's see if we can maybe
pull a graphic to see and head to head
Fabiano versus Yan only uh one win for
yeah no wins for Fabiano this is what I
remembered and I I wanted to
specifically mention that this could be
the break
the the break that Fabi never had
achieved out of the 13 previous games
he never managed to Best nepo In
classical chess there's first time for
everything guess so yeah probably guys
I'm thinking this might be the only
player that Fabi doesn't have a win and
a classical chess
uh I mean he's I think he has wins
against all of the the very very top
players
yep
including Magnus we remember when he won
a singfield cup years ago sure
well that's uh
that's a it's kind of a relief actually
uh to get in that win and to say that
you know against all the top players in
the world I've won at least once
and for nepo he's sitting here saying
okay
how on Earth could I not necessarily
trick my opponent I think we're beyond
that but how do I make it as difficult
as as humanly possible uh what kind of
obstacles can I throw in the pathway of
Fabi does the engine come up with
anything decent or are you keeping your
eye on the car and I I don't see uh the
engine making a good suggestion uh no
I'm keeping my eye on it yes sir but I
don't see any any uh real ideas that
will allow uh black to get some chances
the way that White's pieces are set up
the queen only two the Knight only four
and now that after they try there's some
dark Square weaknesses as well so it's
just a couple of uh more moves precise
moves a couple of more moves and I think
white should be able to win this game I
I must say I do like this move Queen A3
because the the reality to my mind is if
white is just allowed to play Queen B2
followed by B5 you could resign I mean
that's it so at least when you play the
move Queen B Queen A3 you're being that
annoying irritating person that an
opponent is supposed to be right you are
looking towards the E3 Pawn so you're
kind of saying you your queen remain
tethered there and I'm not gonna allow
you Queen B2 I'm probably still going to
play B5 by the way yeah B5 I think
that's just I also like Knight C6 here
is that I think yeah isn't that's oh B5
on the board yeah but I think you're
right I think we had actually seen this
and seen the move Knight because we're
like this is a checkmating attack right
there is a bishop D3 moved there I think
that's why maybe Fabiano didn't play uh
Queens
B5 Queen D3 check them apples out
there's a second Queen D3
okay
so I don't want to trade Queens right
because this is yeah this is where I can
mess things up right here if I trade
queens and allow takes the king is a
little bit too far away to deal with the
D3 Pawn I don't want to lose this guys
if I go Queen
E1 you can take 21 Bishop B5 Queen C1
so I've got okay you gotta take right
yeah I mean you gotta take and then we
have a queen C7 check right he's done it
King
G8
and that picks up the bishop
right King G8 Queen B5 check
King F6 Queen B6 check because he has
black Heaven checks after 23. you can
get seven yes
yes
just a reminder everybody if Bobby wins
this game he will be the sole leader
going in to round five tomorrow so okay
so like but let's say you go
King G8 okay I go check let's say you
move your king doesn't matter I can take
and in this way I keep F4 protected but
at last
we've got the pawn on H4 and this is
what we'd always dreamed Queen A7 yes oh
[Music]
oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh
good morning look at that Queen trade
I'm glad you guys saw that I really you
make me proud we're not sleeping I
uh that's it Queen C5 and Fabiano wins
he resigned wow impressive
uh impressive play as Bobby uh
ground nepo down uh check
King well King f8 was probably of all of
the old places to put his King wasn't f8
the worst place yeah because now Queen
C5 trick and then Knight takes B5 and
the E3 Pawn is protected exactly that
was precipitated resigns on the spots we
were we were expecting King G8
and
thanks to the move Queen A7 check my H4
is a little slow but if I don't have H4
I'm losing I understand so but
with that one in the history books
here's where we stand we have a clear
leader our congratulations to America's
Fabiano caruana with three out of four
he has followed closely by two players
Wesley so Richard Rapport at two and a
half two and a half Ali Reza and Jan
as well as dingler in and Anish Geary
are all at 50 chasing the pack and for
tomorrow here's what we are expecting
with the pairings nepo versus
mvl Duda versus uh Fabi that will be
nice for Rouge versus ding I see that as
a super Marquee matchup Wesley so
against diak maybe Wesley is to be like
okay uh do you get into time trouble
I'll be happy and Anish giri versus
Richie Rapport as round five looks to be
a very exciting round for sure and also
uh as we get ready to wrap up we hope
we'll get an interview with Abby uh
coming up in just a moment uh
it turned out to be a pretty interesting
round after all of our we were a little
bit worried that everything was going to
go five draws there for a moment but uh
these last two games uh victories in
fact uh have made the tournament ever
more interesting absolutely yeah sir and
I'm very impressed by Fabiano I mean he
started a little bit slow but now with
two consecutive wins with the white
pieces he's showing some good
preparation he didn't get much the uh
today out of the opening but he took his
chances and when Jan misplayed this end
game which the kind of vehicle he took
advantage of it he played really well
after that change in a structure after
the move Knight E4 which we both thought
maybe was unnecessary for Yam exactly
but his conversion was very very precise
and he took his time at the right moment
to find this move before and which was
the only way for him to win so far I'm
very impressed by his play and I think
uh uh he has some good chances in the
tournament to win this event absolutely
well you're confident this always builds
as you uh
win uh victories come your confidence
goes up this was the the moment where I
thought that Fabi was
happy with this move F2 F4
yes you weaken your king side and you
weaken the pawn on E3 but putting that
Bishop on E5 under duress because if you
don't play the move F4
uh D5 D4 is on Black's agenda just to
trade off his isolated green pawn and
thanks to this imbalance it it's not
easy to outplay these guys especially
when the positions really balanced and
well kudos to Fabi uh for outplaying
nepo a player he is never defeated
before in 13 attempts it took the 14th
time for him to finally break through
and he is clearly clear first as we're
getting ready for an interview coming up
we hope shortly
absolutely I agree with you it's always
nice to win finally against an opponent
that you never I'm gonna say he really
struggled against but you know he was
probably getting frustrated in some of
these games I'm sure he had some chances
right here and there uh to maybe score a
win but finally getting that win it's uh
it's a huge boost for his confidence and
I think nepo is a player that he's
probably gonna face a lot the next
couple of years perhaps in the future
candidate tournaments or maybe some
other very important events so I think
it's a very very important win for
Fabiano today against young and let's
take a look at our remaining schedule as
tomorrow the players come back for round
five and that's a big day why because
it's a day before the rest day and
everybody before rest day is willing to
put out everything they've got because
they know they get a chance to catch up
uh their battery so expect a big round
tomorrow then after the rest day four
rounds of the road to complete the
tournament and let's just read mind
everybody of round five's pairings
coming up as our tournament leader Favi
he's going to be playing Duda and you
know Duda has not played a great event
he's only at one and a half he's minor
score yes Duda will have white but Bobby
might be feeling it Perugia versus ding
now that's going to be a great clash as
the number one seed Ali Reza farouza up
against the new Chinese world champion
ding Loren and Wesley so
half a point behind Abby well try to do
the same against dioc looking for
opportunity nepo trying to bounce back
versus mvl and the other two and a half
Richie Rapport will have black against
Anish Gary so a nice round coming up
prior to the free day absolutely
and we are just seconds away from our
interview and what question should we
like to ask Fabi
when did he know when did he know that
it was oh when he saw that move before
absolutely that was that was very
special
yeah and the fact that he took his time
he spent more than 10 minutes and left
himself with only a few minutes on a
clock and find found that critical move
before to win the game yes absolutely
wow and let's jump to Bucharest as
Christian is with Abby
first of all I want to bring uh to you a
statistic you've never beaten nepo in a
classical game were you aware of that
I didn't think about it but it's it's
not surprising we we drew a lot of games
that he beat me in suburb in 2019 and I
think those were all we drew four games
in candidates I think yeah he beat me I
mean Instagram I was like completely
winning I I just I suicided
um which uh like with the five pieces I
was winning I just collapsed for no
reason and yes the wrestler draws a lot
of fighting draws like the candidates
were really sharp to two sharp throws
your initial feelings after uh this
grinding Victory okay I had nothing out
of the opening I mean well I I thought
he kind of got careless a little bit and
then I got careless like Bishop C7
allows Knight A4 I mean before Bishop z7
is equal but then he allows Knight A4
and right after I played 92 I was like
why didn't I play Knight A4 and I have a
very pleasant position
um
and okay then it was equal again like
for a long time we were just playing
instantly and nothing was happening
I mean were you harboring any hopes at
this point like who was playing for a
victory were you guys just trying to
like find a repetition what was uh
basically if you played pg8 here I was
actually I was actually going to play
King G1 I didn't see then he so this was
the repetition yeah I did I didn't
really see like what to do
um but then he put his King on
on E7
and I don't know why but it made me like
it doesn't change anything but it made
me like a little bit more optimistic and
then I saw this Knight C2 maneuver and I
was like oh okay like my Queen's getting
in I mean that obviously changes nothing
the position is equal no matter what uh
even if my queen is in but if I get
Queen E5 Knight D4 then
it looks a little bit more more pleasant
for white and then you play this move
right to E4 yeah I was happy because I
could never risk this position I mean
it's of course a draw yeah but if I
don't trade Queens then I absolutely
never risk okay trading Queens can get
dangerous because my queen side is
vulnerable
and
yeah then when he played here I actually
saw this line up to Queen C2 when I
played Queen E2 because I thought Queen
C3 is Supernatural
I thought It's Supernatural and I
basically saw that here he's he's sort
of
um like it's very normal what he's doing
yeah it always looks very logical and I
saw his position and it looked like I'm
making progress although I thought
first I thought that Queen C5 was a draw
based on this and then I saw this very
nice Queen H7
uh because if I trade queens and I don't
think I have any winning chances I mean
with Queen D4 or well for example Queen
D4 Queen D5 take take I don't believe
that this position I have only winning
chances because this king gets in very
quickly but I saw his creative Summit it
looked very interesting
uh and then I thought he would play B5
and I kind of thought that it's a draw
somehow here but I I still thought it's
more pleasant for me uh here I was
already thinking like it is a kind of
borderline winning because
I mean I thought maybe it's a draw here
I didn't see like all the details I was
surprised by Queen A2 I thought Queen C2
but then I saw something here which made
me happy did you feel like he relaxed
prematurely I mean the position was
equal out of the opening it felt like it
was equal throughout the middle game and
then he started playing this dubious
moves especially F5 yeah it was well
already he was gaining difficulties so
normally you shouldn't get into a
situation so you were feeling the
pressure was getting to him at this
point I mean at this point he first of
all he looks unhappy after Queen C2 and
he has no like clear path to a draw I
mean it's probably a draw but he might
have to defend four against three with
queen and Knight against Queen Bishop
that's not very pleasant
um at least he has to like calculate
everything it's not an easy defensive
task I think yeah
and
yeah I was surprised by Queen A2 but
then he found this absolutely brilliant
resource I hadn't seen I thought the
game's over I was like waiting more or
less because if if he takes uh okay I
take both pawns and that's what I want
because then he can't kill my knight
anymore or he can pended but I can
always break it after King I was like
um first I thought Queen C5 must be
winning but then Bishop B3 queen of 80
as Bishop G8 and I thought maybe this is
winning but I couldn't quite see it and
I was trying all sorts of moves here
like I literally was thinking about
every every possible queen of like Queen
C3 even Bishop C4 and King G1 for
example it was like part of my thought
process yeah because
if my knight gets to D4 like and I win
the F5 Pawn then he just collapses like
let's say this type of position
um or here yeah let's say queen G8 to
Queen F5 I mean the problem is that he's
gonna lose
but I I saw something that bothered me
and then I spent like all my time and I
played this okay I repeated once I
played this thing which really worried
me because I'm pinned and
I saw like some G5 stuff but then I
thought like a G5 I take take and King
E1
and queen D2 and somehow I free myself
and I mean even up to the end I was like
very very confused with everything yeah
I mean here I was like okay but once you
got the Knight to D4 everything
seems secure right your thing seems
secure you're not getting paint anymore
still with one minute I'm not like super
confident of course
and then Queen D3 yeah I mean it's very
interesting try but I'm lucky I have a
picture of Queen C1
um
I mean also probably 9c6 is winning but
yeah it's it's like you have to kind of
keep working for for it it's winning but
you know with one minute anything can
happen but yeah once I saw his Queen see
when I was very happy because uh I win
the bishop Bobby back to back victories
uh with the white pieces you made the
best possible outcome whenever you have
the white pieces happen
um how do you feel about your
performance up to this point and what's
the strategy for tomorrow against a more
or less struggling player Duda with the
black pieces okay this is a very very
important game it's it's really
satisfying uh also because uh I mean Jan
just played a world championship match
and I didn't achieve anything from the
opening but still I was out playing him
so so it's very satisfying
um still of course I mean the tournament
situation is good but the situation is
good but still early and yeah dude with
black I I am quite tired so I do want to
um to recover some energy before the
game tomorrow Bobby will let you go get
some energy and we'll see you tomorrow
it's back to you thank you Christian or
congratulations to Fabi a little
apologies for Nasi Nasi is having a
coughing fit as am I uh but on her
behalf on my behalf thank you so much
for joining us and making uh this event
such a remember a remarkable one and VAR
just bring the broadcast to a close uh
round four
quite some quite a memory for Fabi in
the history books as he finally Best
nepo In classical chess absolutely yes
sir Fabi must be very happy because he
won this game against Jan it was not
easy he didn't get anything out of the
opening but he mentioned to uh as he
mentioned he managed to outplay him in
uh from a very equal position now is a
clear leader and I think he has very
good chances so I'm looking forward to
his game tomorrow against Duda and the
other games as well so it was a very
very exciting it was a lot of fun
analyzing the games with you guys
absolutely and finally let's just jump
to Bucharest and get some final thoughts
for her from Christian
well uh a round that definitely started
slow just like the game between Fabiano
and Jan but in the end it was once again
an explosive round two out of five
decisive results and I have to say Ali
Reza winning with the black pieces that
was a huge result and of course winning
against uh the Challenger napomnia she
for Fabiano that was just an incredible
feature and of course back-to-back
victories you you win one game in this
type of closed events with the elite
level players and you feel good about
yourself you've went back to back games
and that can give you just an incredible
boost of confidence and this is what I'm
feeling from Fabi and whenever Fabi has
that confidence dialed in he's a
dangerous man so definitely I'm looking
forward to see what round five the day
before the rest day is going to bring
tomorrow
thank you Christian fabi's got his Mojo
working we'll work for him tomorrow
we'll find out thank you everybody for
joining our broadcast and sharing your
day with us tell your friends where
you're hanging out and we'll see you all
tomorrow
[Music]
thank you
this has been a presentation of the St
Louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the St Louis
chess club is prohibited